The Inca's my ancestors ruled from Chile to Quito, treating their vassals as their own children. They did not steal and killed only when it served justice. They kept order and reason in the provinces. But now the bearded ones have entered our land. They preach one thing and do another. They have no fear of God and no shame. They treat us like dogs. Their greed is such that there is no temple they have not plundered.
印加人，我的祖先，从智利统治到基多，视臣民如己出。他们不偷窃，只在伸张正义时才杀戮。他们在各省维持秩序与理性。但现在，那些长胡子的人进入了我们的土地。他们说一套做一套。他们既不敬畏上帝，也不知羞耻。他们像对待狗一样对待我们。他们的贪婪到了极点，没有哪座神庙没被他们洗劫过。
In fact, if all the snow turned to gold and silver it would not satisfy them. They keep our sisters as their concubines behaving like animals. They want to divide up all the provinces, giving one to each so that they can loot them. Their goal is to see us so downtrodden, so enslaved, that we will be fit only to find them precious medals, and to give them our women. Which Spaniard have we injured? That they should make such cruel war on us with these horses and weapons of iron. I believe it would not be just or honourable for us to consent to this. So let us strive with all our might to kill these cruel enemies or die in the attempt. So that was Manco, our emperor of the Inca's, addressing a secret gathering of his king.
事实上，就算所有的雪都变成了金银，也无法满足他们。他们把我们的姐妹当作妾室，行径如同禽兽。他们想要瓜分所有的省份，每人分一块，好让他们去掠夺。他们的目标是让我们变得如此卑微、如此被奴役，以至于我们只配为他们寻找珍贵的金属，并把我们的女人献给他们。我们伤害过哪个西班牙人吗？以至于他们要用这些马匹和铁制武器对我们发动如此残酷的战争。我相信，如果我们同意这一点，既不公正也不光荣。所以，让我们竭尽全力杀死这些残忍的敌人，或者在尝试中死去。这就是曼科，我们的印加皇帝，在向他的国王秘密集会发表讲话。
and supporters in Kusko in the autumn of 1535, offering a perspective there on Spanish rule that you have to say, I mean, is not unjustified, perhaps slightly whitewashing the amiability of the Incan regime, but, you know, needs must. And we are three years now into the conquest of the Inca's. And now, Dominic, you have written, the story is approaching its thrilling climax. I mean, it's probably not that thrilling for the Inca's, is it? No, it's not that thrilling. Big sports. alert. A lot of people are going to die in the next two episodes. I mean, that's the nature of history, but they die in exciting ways in these episodes. So that makes it particularly thrilling.
以及1535年秋天在库斯科的支持者们，他在那里提出的关于西班牙统治的观点，你不得不说，我的意思是，并非毫无道理，也许稍微粉饰了印加政权的友善，但是，你知道，形势所迫。我们现在已经进入征服印加人的第三年了。多米尼克，你写道，故事正接近其激动人心的高潮。我的意思是，这对印加人来说可能并不那么激动人心，对吧？不，这并不那么激动人心。剧透预警。在接下来的两集里，很多人会死。我的意思是，这就是历史的本质，但他们在这些剧集中以令人兴奋的方式死去。所以这让它变得特别激动人心。
Along with some beard shaving and guava fruit throwing, which is an unexpected angle. Yes. Definitely look forward to the throwing of guava fruit. And also, if you're a fan of garotting, this is not quite at the Lopé de Geeret level of garotting, but it's up there. And Dominic, fair to say that guava fruit chucking actually isn't going to be the worst of it. So, you know, if you like torture, listen on. If you don't, or you've got children with you, just perhaps, you know, rain it in a bit. So let's set the scene. Francisco Pizarro and his fellow conquistadors had sailed down the Pacific coast from Panama. They'd marched inland. They'd captured and killed the emperor at a walper. They'd pocketed the biggest ransom in history.
还有一些刮胡子和扔番石榴的戏码，这是一个意想不到的角度。是的。绝对期待扔番石榴的场面。而且，如果你是绞刑的粉丝，这虽然还没达到洛佩·德·阿吉雷那种绞刑的水平，但也差不多了。多米尼克，公平地说，扔番石榴实际上还不是最糟糕的部分。所以，你知道，如果你喜欢折磨，那就继续听。如果你不喜欢，或者你有孩子在身边，也许，你知道，稍微收敛一点。那么让我们来设定一下场景。弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗和他的征服者同伴们从巴拿马沿着太平洋海岸航行。他们向内陆进军。他们俘虏并杀死了皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕。他们装进了历史上最大的赎金。
Last week, we heard how they marched on the capital Kusko. They installed a puppet emperor in this chapmanco, then very young. and they crushed opposition in the northern part of the empire in what's now Ecuador. But in today's episode, they will be facing their biggest challenge yet. So an uprising led by Manco and a street-by-street, Starlingrad-style battle for control of the capital, Kusco. So it's a very dramatic story. And let's start with the man who you ventriloquized, so admirably Tom, Manco. A noble man.
上周，我们听说了他们是如何向首都库斯科进军的。他们在这个当时还很年轻的曼科身上安装了一个傀儡皇帝。他们镇压了帝国北部（即现在的厄瓜多尔）的反对势力。但在今天的剧集中，他们将面临迄今为止最大的挑战。一场由曼科领导的起义，以及一场为了控制首都库斯科而进行的逐条街道式的斯大林格勒式战役。所以这是一个非常戏剧性的故事。让我们从你模仿得如此出色的人开始，汤姆，曼科。一个高尚的人。
I feel I conveyed the nobility. You totally did. You totally did. I think the Spanish themselves, the Spanish chroniclers and memoirists who wrote about Manco in the middle of the 16th century, absolutely saw him as a noble character, even as a heroic character, actually. A worthy adversary. So we know very little about him before Pizarro met him outside Kuzko and basically adopted him as his puppet. So he was a brother of Huasca, the defeated claimant in the Inca Civil War. He's been on the run from Attawalper's men.
我觉得我传达出了那种高贵感。你完全做到了。你完全做到了。我认为西班牙人自己，那些在16世纪中叶撰写关于曼科的西班牙编年史家和回忆录作者，绝对把他看作一个高尚的人物，甚至实际上是一个英雄人物。一个值得尊敬的对手。所以，在皮萨罗在库斯科城外遇见他并基本上收他为傀儡之前，我们对他知之甚少。他是瓦斯卡尔的兄弟，也就是印加内战中失败的竞争者。他一直在躲避阿塔瓦尔帕的人。
He's probably in his late teens when he meets Pizarro. When they arrived in Cusco in November 1533, he was greeted as a liberator. He was clearly popular with the crowds. There's no hint of a rising against him or resentment. And actually at first all went very well. Six months later, June 1534, Pizarro's secretary Pedro Sancho wrote that his coronation has proved highly successful. All the chiefs come to serve him and pay homage to the emperor, by which he means Charles
当他遇见皮萨罗时，他可能才十几岁。当他们在1533年11月抵达库斯科时，他被当作解放者受到欢迎。他显然很受民众欢迎。没有任何迹象表明人们对他有反抗或怨恨。事实上，起初一切都很顺利。六个月后，1534年6月，皮萨罗的秘书佩德罗·桑乔写道，他的加冕典礼非常成功。所有的酋长都来侍奉他并向皇帝致敬，他指的是查理
the 5th of Spain. because of him. And actually the Spanish sent several reports that summer to Spain, saying we're very pleased with him. He's doing very well. All is good. However, Manco obviously is facing some pretty formidable challenges. So, as we've said so many times,
西班牙的五世。因为他。事实上，西班牙人在那个夏天向西班牙发送了几份报告，说我们对他非常满意。他做得很好。一切都好。然而，曼科显然面临着一些相当艰巨的挑战。所以，正如我们多次说过的，
the fact that there has been a civil war has left the Inca Empire, Tawantin Soyo, in ruins. There are parts of the empire where local ethnic groups have tried to throw off Inca rule. I mean, that's contradicting the whole we treated them like children. Exactly, of course, the Inkers, as we've described in our very first episode, a pretty terrifying overlords. I mean, they will destroy your village and move you, you know,
内战的事实使印加帝国，即塔万廷苏尤，陷入了废墟。帝国的一些地方，当地的族群试图摆脱印加的统治。我的意思是，这与我们对待他们像孩子一样的说法相矛盾。没错，当然，印加人，正如我们在第一集所描述的那样，是相当可怕的霸主。我的意思是，如果他们愿意，他们会摧毁你的村庄并把你搬迁到，你知道，
hundreds of miles across the empire and force you to speak Quechua, their language, you know, if they want to. So local kind of warlords have taken control in some areas. People have thrown off the Inca sun cult and gone back to their old gods and things. And as John Heming, in his brilliant book about the conquest of Peru, says, Manco had to try to restore the sort of cult of the Inca, to take over control of the administration, to assert his primacy as supreme ruler. He had to revive the prestige of Kusko. He had to revive the prestige of the official religion, all of this kind of thing.
帝国各地数百英里之外，并强迫你说克丘亚语，也就是他们的语言。所以当地的一些军阀在某些地区夺取了控制权。人们抛弃了印加太阳崇拜，回到了他们古老的神灵等等。正如约翰·海明在他关于征服秘鲁的精彩著作中所说，曼科必须努力恢复印加的某种崇拜，接管行政管理权，确立他作为最高统治者的首要地位。他必须重振库斯科的威望。他必须重振官方宗教的威望，所有这些事情。
Now, the Spanish, up to a point, are useful allies in this. He presumably sees them as so many people do in these sort of stories as merely a new factor in the existing kind of political landscape of Peru and one that he can harness and use. So Dominic, at this point, Manco assumes that everything can carry on pretty much as it always has done. He doesn't think that the Spanish essentially have changed everything. No, because we're talking about very small numbers of people. I mean, at the end of this decade, the Spanish did a census of their own population in New Castile, as they called it, and we were talking about 4,000 people. So at this stage, we're probably talking about half that, something like that. I mean, a tiny number, right?
现在，西班牙人在某种程度上是这方面的有用盟友。他大概像许多人在这类故事中所做的那样，仅仅把他们看作秘鲁现有政治格局中的一个新因素，一个他可以利用和驾驭的因素。所以多米尼克，在这一点上，曼科认为一切都可以像往常一样继续下去。他不认为西班牙人基本上改变了一切。不，因为我们谈论的是非常少的人。我的意思是，在这个十年结束时，西班牙人对他们在新卡斯蒂利亚（他们这样称呼它）的人口进行了普查，我们谈论的是4000人。所以在这个阶段，我们可能谈论的是这个数字的一半，诸如此类。我的意思是，一个极小的数字，对吧？
In an empire of 12 million people, 2,000 maximum, probably hundreds at this stage. So why would he think differently? These are elite mercenaries to whom he owes his throne, but they're not going to be a factor forever, and there's probably not that many more of them. And of course, in this, he is completely nuttly wrong. Anyway, at first the signs are all good. He builds himself a new palace in Kusco. And interestingly, quite a difference, I think, with Mexico. The Spanish don't seem terribly keen on pushing the program of Christianisation. So, you know, Manco is completely free to continue with the religious rituals that enshrine his primacy as the Sapa Inca. There's a lovely description by a young priest called Christobald de Molina of a ploughing festival in April 1535. It's one of the
在一个拥有1200万人口的帝国里，最多2000人，在这个阶段可能只有几百人。所以他为什么要另想呢？这些是他欠下王位的精英雇佣兵，但他们不会永远是一个因素，而且可能没有那么多。当然，在这点上，他完全大错特错了。无论如何，起初迹象都很好。他在库斯科为自己建造了一座新宫殿。有趣的是，我认为与墨西哥有很大的不同。西班牙人似乎对推行基督教化计划并不太热衷。所以，你知道，曼科完全可以自由地继续进行那些确立他作为萨帕·印加首要地位的宗教仪式。一位名叫克里斯托瓦尔·德·莫利纳的年轻牧师对1535年4月的犁地节有一个可爱的描述。这是我们拥有的
best descriptions we have actually of an Inca religious festival. They bring all the effigies out from the temples at daybreak. The lords of Cusco wore rich silver cloaks and tunics with shining circlets of fine gold on their heads. They formed up in a procession and waited in deep silence for the sun to rise. And as the sun began to rise, they began to chant in splendid harmony. And as it continued to rise, they chanted higher. And all day they chant, Manco is kind of leading them. And then we're told as the sun began to sink,
关于印加宗教节日最好的描述之一。他们在黎明时分把所有的雕像从神庙里拿出来。库斯科的领主们穿着华丽的银色斗篷和束腰外衣，头上戴着闪亮的纯金圆环。他们排成队列，在深沉的寂静中等待太阳升起。当太阳开始升起时，他们开始以宏伟的和谐节奏吟唱。随着太阳继续升起，他们的吟唱声越来越高。他们整天都在吟唱，曼科在某种程度上领导着他们。然后我们被告知，当太阳开始下沉时，
the Indians showed great sadness at its departure and allowed their voices to die away. And as it completely disappears, they made this act of reverence, worshipping it in the deepest humility. And then they all went back to their homes and the effigges and relics were returned to their shrines and temples.
印第安人对它的离去表现出极大的悲伤，并让他们的声音逐渐消失。当它完全消失时，他们进行了这种崇敬的行为，以最深沉的谦卑崇拜它。然后他们都回到了自己的家中，雕像和遗物被送回了他们的神龛和神庙。
So if you're part of that ceremony, which clearly Christabel de Molina, you know, the way he writes about it, It's respectful, isn't it? Yeah, he's respectful and he finds it clearly quite moving. There's this illusion of harmony and unity, that the world is back on its axis, that everything has been restored after the chaos of the Civil War. But there are three fracture lines that are widening all the time.
所以如果你是那个仪式的一部分，显然克里斯托瓦尔·德·莫利纳，你知道，他描写它的方式，它是尊重的，不是吗？是的，他很尊重，而且他显然觉得这相当感人。这是一种和谐与统一的错觉，世界回到了它的轴心上，内战后的混乱之后一切都已恢复。但有三条裂痕一直在扩大。
So the first is between the Spanish and the Inca's. The second is among the Inca's themselves, and the third is among the Spaniards themselves. And that's arguably the most dangerous of the three. So if we start with the Spanish and the Inca's, when we ended last time, we were talking about how the Spanish were starting to behave very badly. They're starting to loot gold and silver. They're treating the priests with contempt. And, you know, a really big thing, Pizarro is starting to distribute estates, landed estates, to his fellow conquistadors. These are the encomiendas that become such a feature of kind of the settler colonial world of Spanish Peru. And he's got a big problem, hasn't he, that as more and more people come, so from Spain, so they want encomiendas as well.
第一条是在西班牙人和印加人之间。第二条是在印加人自己之间，第三条是在西班牙人自己之间。这可以说是三者中最危险的。所以如果我们从西班牙人和印加人开始，当我们上次结束时，我们谈到了西班牙人是如何开始表现得非常糟糕的。他们开始掠夺金银。他们轻视祭司。而且，你知道，一件非常大的事情，皮萨罗开始向他的征服者同伴分配地产，土地地产。这些就是后来成为西班牙秘鲁定居者殖民世界特征的“监护征赋制”。他有一个大问题，不是吗？随着越来越多的人从西班牙来到这里，他们也想要监护征赋。
And that is an increasing source of pressure on his ability to maintain peace with the Inca's. Dead right. It's not just they want encomienders. It's that they arrive and they think they're going to get loads of gold. And they arrive and there's no gold because it's been given out. And so they say, well, if I can't have any gold, you better give me some land and somebody to work on the land. And so Pizarro is basically giving away more and more and ignoring requests from the court in Spain from royal officials. Please, when you stop distributing land that you don't own. And his other wheeze is to send them off into the jungle or into kind of remote deserts to go looking for lost cities with gold. A big feature. A big feature that will carry on.
这对他维持与印加人和平的能力构成了越来越大的压力。完全正确。他们想要的不仅仅是监护征赋。而是他们到达后认为自己会得到大量的黄金。但他们到达时却没有黄金，因为黄金已经被分光了。所以他们说，好吧，如果我不能得到黄金，你最好给我一些土地和一些在土地上干活的人。所以皮萨罗基本上是在分发越来越多的土地，并无视西班牙宫廷和皇家官员的要求。请停止分发不属于你的土地。他的另一个诡计是把他们打发到丛林或偏远的沙漠中去寻找失落的黄金之城。这是一个大特征。一个将持续下去的大特征。
So you start to get reports that from local towns and villages that people no longer see the Spaniards, the liberators who've entered the chaos of the Civil War. they see them as occupiers in their own right. And as so often with occupations, military occupations, a really key fault line is how the occupiers treat the local women. So as in Mexico, we had Pedro de Alvarado on the show last week, didn't we, an old associate of the rest of history. And you mentioned that he had got this wife, I think she was called Donna Louisa, wasn't she?
所以你开始收到来自当地城镇和村庄的报告，人们不再把西班牙人看作是进入内战混乱的解放者。他们把他们看作是名副其实的占领者。正如军事占领中经常出现的那样，一个非常关键的断层线是占领者如何对待当地妇女。所以就像在墨西哥一样，我们上周在节目中请到了佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多，不是吗？他是历史其余部分的老搭档。你提到他有这个妻子，我想她叫唐娜·路易莎，对吧？
Yeah. In Mexico, who is buried with him in the cathedral in Guatemala. And he became the governor of Guatemala. This is a very standard thing, not becoming the governor, but for the Spanish to take local wives, as they call them actually kind of mistresses or concumines. So Atta Welper had already given Pizarro a half-sister of his called Kisbe Kusi, who was 18 years old. The Spanish called her Inyes. Pizaro nicknamed her Pizpita, which is a water thrush from his native extramajura. It's a sweet name.
是的。在墨西哥，她和他在危地马拉的大教堂里合葬。他成为了危地马拉的总督。这是一件非常标准的事情，不是成为总督，而是西班牙人娶当地妻子，他们实际上称之为情妇或妾室。所以阿塔瓦尔帕已经给了皮萨罗一个他同父异母的姐妹，名叫基斯贝·库西，她当时18岁。西班牙人叫她伊内斯。皮萨罗给她起了个绰号叫皮兹皮塔，这是他家乡埃斯特雷马杜拉的一种水鸫。这是一个甜蜜的名字。
And he actually treated her pretty well. He called her his wife. She would dine with him and his captains. She had two children by him. Eventually he got bored of her and he married her off to another conquistador called Francisco de Ampero. And actually their descendants, the Amperos, ended up being one of Peru's most powerful political families. Because in Incan society, women do play kind of a key role as power brokers, as people who influence the policy of their husbands and their families. and, you know, with Alvarado or with Pizarro or whoever,
他实际上对她相当不错。他称她为他的妻子。她会和他以及他的船长们一起用餐。她为他生了两个孩子。最终他厌倦了她，把她嫁给了另一个名叫弗朗西斯科·德·安佩罗的征服者。事实上，他们的后代，安佩罗家族，最终成为了秘鲁最有权势的政治家族之一。因为在印加社会，女性确实扮演着关键的权力掮客角色，作为影响丈夫和家庭政策的人。而且，你知道，无论是阿尔瓦拉多还是皮萨罗，或者其他任何人，
there is a sense that when the marriage works, it's to the benefit of both sides. And throughout this story, I mean, we'll see there are Incan women or indeed women from other peoples who stick by the Spaniards. So that is true, but I don't think we should downgrade the element of coercion that is often there. Of course not. You know, as we will see, there is incredible violence as well. But for the Spaniards, it is an option.
有一种感觉是，当婚姻有效时，这对双方都有利。在整个故事中，我的意思是，我们会看到有印加女性，或者确实是来自其他民族的女性，她们坚持追随西班牙人。所以这是真的，但我认为我们不应该降低其中往往存在的强制因素。当然不是。你知道，正如我们将看到的，也有令人难以置信的暴力。但对于西班牙人来说，这是一个选择。
that many of these women are very shrewd political players. Yes, that's absolutely true. That's absolutely fair. But to give another example, Diego de Al-Magro, who is Pizarro's business partner, his very disputatious and resentful business partner, Al-Magro married another daughter of Huenna Capac, so the old emperor.
许多这些女性是非常精明的政治参与者。是的，那绝对是真的。那绝对是公平的。但再举一个例子，迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗，他是皮萨罗的商业伙伴，他那个非常爱争吵和怨恨的商业伙伴，阿尔马格罗娶了瓦伊纳·卡帕克的另一个女儿，也就是那位老皇帝。
So this is Manco's sister, Marca Chimbo. She's very rich, she's clearly very impressive. She's one of these people you're talking about, Tom. The Spanish sources say, she would have inherited the Inca Empire if she had been a man. But Almagro treats her very badly. She was repeatedly dishonoured, for she was very pretty and of a gentle nature, and she caught the pox.
所以这是曼科的姐妹，马尔卡·钦博。她非常富有，显然非常令人印象深刻。她就是你所说的那些人之一，汤姆。西班牙史料说，如果她是男人，她本可以继承印加帝国。但阿尔马格罗对她非常不好。她多次受到羞辱，因为她非常漂亮且性格温和，而且她还染上了天花。
So, I mean, who knows what's going on there, but there's nothing good, I would say. The Rankine File, too, insist on taking local women as mistresses. Now, some sources say this was consensual. An Indian woman who proved most attractive to the Spaniards prided herself on the fact. But at the same time, a different source. woman who was good looking was safe, it was a miracle if she escaped the Spaniards. And you can see how both those things could possibly be true at once. The Spaniards might seem prestigious and high status, and so people might be attracted by them,
所以，我的意思是，谁知道那里发生了什么，但我会说没什么好事。普通士兵也坚持要娶当地妇女为情妇。现在，一些资料说这是双方自愿的。一个对西班牙人表现出极大吸引力的印第安妇女以此为荣。但与此同时，另一份资料说，长得好看的女人是安全的，如果她能逃脱西班牙人的魔掌简直是奇迹。你可以看出这两件事怎么可能同时是真的。西班牙人可能看起来很有声望和地位，所以人们可能会被他们吸引，
but at the same time the Spanish are behaving increasingly badly. Well, also, I mean, you hope that if you can find one who will protect you a Spaniard, then you need that. Well, you do need protection because the Spanish, I mean, to give an example of the coercive element, they supposedly had a test, and this is from a Spanish source, I think, They have a test to see if a girl is old enough for them to sleep with her. They would hit her unexpectedly from behind with a rolled cape. If she remained upright, she was considered sufficiently old.
但与此同时，西班牙人的表现越来越糟糕。嗯，而且，我的意思是，你希望如果你能找到一个能保护你的西班牙人，那么你就需要那个。嗯，你确实需要保护，因为西班牙人，我的意思是，举一个强制因素的例子，他们据说有一个测试，这是来自一份西班牙资料，我想，他们有一个测试来看看女孩是否足够大可以和他们睡觉。他们会从背后用卷起的斗篷出其不意地打她。如果她保持直立，她就被认为足够大了。
So this is obviously a problem for Manco. You know, Manco is regarded as the Spaniards man, as their puppet to some extent. He entered the city with Pizarro's troops. He stood there nodding and smiling when Pizarro read out the requirement. So some of the Inca release start by early 1535. to say, you know, is he the right man? Is he standing up to these people or is he just there at all? And what makes this so dangerous is that the Spaniards themselves
所以这显然是曼科的一个问题。你知道，曼科在某种程度上被视为西班牙人的手下，他们的傀儡。他随皮萨罗的军队进入城市。当皮萨罗宣读要求时，他站在那里点头微笑。所以一些印加人从1535年初开始说，你知道，他是合适的人选吗？他是在反抗这些人，还是仅仅在那里？而让这一切变得如此危险的是，西班牙人自己
have started to fall out with each other. So all through this series, the feud between Pizarro and Al-Magro, the two business partners, has been getting worse and worse. Remember that Pizarro went to Spain, he came back with a great title for himself and basically nothing for Al-Magro.
已经开始互相闹翻了。所以在这整个系列中，皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗这两个商业伙伴之间的不和变得越来越严重。记住，皮萨罗去了西班牙，他回来时为自己赢得了伟大的头衔，而基本上没有给阿尔马格罗任何东西。
Then Al-Magro turned up late, as agreed, and Pizarro wouldn't give him a share of the ransom or a fair share of the ransom. early 1535, Pizarro has moved to the coast to found the city of Lima. Basically, he wants a base nearer the coast and he's got this new city. And he says to Almagro, you can be the lieutenant governor of Cusco. But Almagro's men who are mostly newcomers start feuding with the old guard who have been there for a year and a half now.
然后阿尔马格罗迟到了，正如约定的那样，皮萨罗不给他赎金的份额或公平的赎金份额。1535年初，皮萨罗搬到了海岸，建立了利马市。基本上，他想要一个靠近海岸的基地，他有了这个新城市。他对阿尔马格罗说，你可以担任库斯科的副总督。但阿尔马格罗的手下，大多是新来者，开始与已经在那待了一年半的老卫队发生争执。
And these are led by Pizarro's younger brothers, Juan and Gonzalo. It's got a very long story short. They start brawling in the central square. the Almagristas, as they're called, Almagros faction, and Juan and Gonzalo's faction. And there's all sorts of going on, kind of royal officials have to separate them. And basically, Manco has to choose. Is he going to go with Juan and Gonzalo, or is he going to go with Almagro? Now, you might expect that because he owes his throne to the Pizarro brothers, he will pick the Pizarro's.
这些人由皮萨罗的弟弟胡安和贡萨洛领导。长话短说。他们在中央广场开始斗殴，阿尔马格罗派（正如他们所称的那样）和胡安与贡萨洛的派系。各种事情都在发生，皇家官员不得不把他们分开。基本上，曼科必须做出选择。他是要和胡安与贡萨洛站在一起，还是和阿尔马格罗站在一起？现在，你可能会认为，因为他欠皮萨罗兄弟王位，他会选择皮萨罗。
But no. Unfortunately, Juan and Gonzalo, who I just... described in the first episode as variously affable, noble, magnanimous, virtuous. Yeah, how's that working out? They've let the Pizarro family, the town of Trujillo, the province of Extra Madura and Spain down very badly. They've really behaved poorly. Because basically, with their older brother, Francisco, away on the coast, they've cast off all restraints and they're disgracing themselves. They both want local women.
但不。不幸的是，胡安和贡萨洛，我刚才在第一集中描述为和蔼可亲、高尚、宽宏大量、品德高尚的人。是的，那进展如何？他们让皮萨罗家族、特鲁希略镇、西班牙埃斯特雷马杜拉省非常失望。他们的表现真的很差。因为基本上，随着他们的哥哥弗朗西斯科在海岸，他们抛弃了所有的约束，正在丢人现眼。他们都想要当地的女人。
Juan kidnaps Manko's younger sister who's called Inkyl Koya, even though, and I quote, she was very young and an unmarried maiden. He kept her locked in his house where he made her sleep with him. But Gonzalo is just as bad. He sets his sights on her older sister, Cura Ocillo, who is already Manco's wife. So she's Manco's wife and his sister. This is very Ptolemaic behavior, but this is standard for the Inca's.
胡安绑架了曼科的妹妹，名叫因基尔·科亚，尽管，我引用一下，“她非常年轻，是一个未婚少女”。他把她锁在自己的房子里，强迫她和他睡觉。但贡萨洛也一样坏。他盯上了她的大姐库拉·奥西略，她已经是曼科的妻子了。所以她是曼科的妻子，也是他的姐妹。这是非常托勒密式的行为，但这对于印加人来说是标准的。
the high priest, who was also Manco's brother, so her half-brother as well, tried to stop him and said, you know, you shouldn't be trying to sleep with this woman. And Gonzalo said to him, don't you know what sort of men we Spaniards are? By the king's life, if you don't shut up, I'll slit you open and cut you into little pieces. So what is going on here? It seems really odd that these men would deliberately humiliate and insult the man who is so important to their maintenance of ruling Costco and the empire more generally. See, I don't think it is that odd. I think it's human nature. They see him as their puppet, their bullies. They have a little bit of contempt for him.
大祭司，他也是曼科的兄弟，所以也是她同父异母的兄弟，试图阻止他并说，你知道，你不应该试图和这个女人睡觉。贡萨洛对他说，你不知道我们西班牙人是什么样的人吗？以国王的生命起誓，如果你不闭嘴，我就把你剖开，切成小块。那么这里发生了什么？这些男人故意羞辱和侮辱那个对他们维持库斯科统治和更广泛的帝国统治如此重要的人，这似乎真的很奇怪。看，我不认为这很奇怪。我认为这是人性。他们把他看作是他们的傀儡，他们的欺凌对象。他们对他有一点蔑视。
They have weapons and he doesn't really. He's dependent on them. They don't speak his language. They look down on him and his customs. And over time, I think these guys who remember, they're not educated men, they're tough, hard men from basically the Wild West. But they know the stakes. I mean, they're not naive. They understand that they need to maintain, you know, a degree of income and support for their very precarious regime in Kusko. It just seems very odd. And it may, I mean, maybe you're right that it is a deliberate attempt to humiliate Manco.
他们有武器，而他真的没有。他依赖他们。他们不会说他的语言。他们看不起他和他的习俗。随着时间的推移，我认为这些家伙，记住，他们不是受过教育的人，他们是来自基本上是狂野西部的强硬、坚韧的人。但他们知道赌注。我的意思是，他们并不天真。他们明白，他们需要维持，你知道，一定程度的收入和支持，以维持他们在库斯科非常不稳定的政权。这看起来真的很奇怪。而且可能，我的意思是，也许你是对的，这是一种故意羞辱曼科的尝试。
Well, we'll see them. They really do humiliate him later on, don't they? Or is it the fact that they are princesses, the key thing, that if they can marry the princess, then perhaps they can, you know, hopes of founding a royal dynasty. It does seem unwise, I guess. is unwise. They're unwise people. They will behave in the next two episodes. All of these people will behave incredibly unwisely. I mean, you can't deny that because I know you've read the notes.
嗯，我们会看到他们。他们后来确实羞辱了他，不是吗？还是因为她们是公主，这是关键，如果他们能娶到公主，那么也许他们可以，你知道，有建立皇朝的希望。这似乎不明智，我想。是不明智的。他们是不明智的人。他们会在接下来的两集里表现出来。所有这些人都会表现得极其不明智。我的意思是，你不能否认这一点，因为我知道你读过笔记。
They will behave really, really, recklessly, poorly, hot-headedly. But I still think they're not fools. It seems peculiar. There's a sense of something not quite being explained here. I don't think that it can just be a matter of, oh, that I fancy them. Because they both fancy princesses. Yeah. Who are the sisters of the Inca? And you feel that that can't be coincidence. I don't know about that. I think all of the Spanish go for high-born women generally. Yeah, but these are the highest-born, aren't they?
他们会表现得非常、非常鲁莽、糟糕、冲动。但我仍然认为他们不是傻瓜。这看起来很特别。这里有一种感觉，有些事情没有完全解释清楚。我不认为这仅仅是一个“哦，我喜欢她们”的问题。因为他们都喜欢公主。是的。她们是印加人的姐妹。你觉得那不可能是巧合。我不知道。我认为所有的西班牙人通常都追求出身高贵的女性。是的，但她们是出身最高的，不是吗？
They are, but that's not necessarily different from how the Spanish behaved in Mexico. It's a bit like Cleopatra only sleeping with very powerful men. Maybe. I mean, anyway, Manco actually offers Gonzalo money to get back to the story. Manco offers Gonzalo loads of silver. And Gonzalo said to him, all this silver is fine, but it's the woman I really want. And Manco did a mad thing where he got her sister's companion, her friend. He forced her to dress up as his sister to try and fool Gonzalo.
她们是，但这并不一定与西班牙人在墨西哥的行为有什么不同。这有点像克利奥帕特拉只和非常有权势的男人睡觉。也许吧。我的意思是，无论如何，曼科实际上给贡萨洛钱，回到故事上来。曼科给贡萨洛大量的白银。贡萨洛对他说，所有的白银都很好，但我真正想要的是那个女人。曼科做了一件疯狂的事，他找来了她姐妹的同伴，她的朋友。他强迫她打扮成他姐妹的样子，试图愚弄贡萨洛。
Gonzalo was not fooled. And eventually he got his hands on Kura Oklo, who actually worse is going to happen to her in the next episode, I'm afraid. So Manco is very bitter about all this, and he decides to side with Al Magro in the feuding. And this then creates yet another split because some of Manco's relatives say, well, that's mad. you should be siding with the Pizarro's. So the factualism now sort of seeps like a poison into Manco's court. One evening, Manco becomes absolutely terrified that these other Inca's are going to murder him. And he ends up fleeing to El Magro's house and hiding under his bed, which seems a weird thing to do.
贡萨洛没有被愚弄。最终他抓住了库拉·奥克洛，恐怕在下一集中她会遭遇更糟糕的事情。所以曼科对这一切感到非常痛苦，他决定在争斗中站在阿尔马格罗一边。这又造成了另一次分裂，因为曼科的一些亲戚说，好吧，那太疯狂了。你应该站在皮萨罗一边。所以派系斗争现在像毒药一样渗入了曼科的宫廷。一天晚上，曼科变得非常害怕这些印加人会谋杀他。他最终逃到了阿尔马格罗的房子里，躲在他的床下，这似乎是一件奇怪的事情。
And while he's doing that, loads of other Spaniards find out, and they rush to Manco's house and start looting it. So when he comes back in the next day, he says, can I have my stuff back? And they say, no, you know, you went and hid under the bed. we've got your stuff, you snooze you lose, basically. Anyway, this is all obviously very chaotic and very bad for the Spanish regime. So Francisco Pizarro rushes back from Lima and to try and sort this out. And he says, okay, I'm going to try and sort this out. And what I'm going to do is, Al Magro, I think you should go to Chile.
当他这样做的时候，许多其他西班牙人发现了，他们冲进曼科的房子开始洗劫它。所以当他第二天回来时，他说，我能拿回我的东西吗？他们说，不，你知道，你躲在床下。我们拿到了你的东西，你打瞌睡你就输了，基本上。无论如何，这一切显然非常混乱，对西班牙政权非常不利。所以弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗从利马赶回来试图解决这个问题。他说，好吧，我要试着解决这个问题。我要做的是，阿尔马格罗，我认为你应该去智利。
And basically, there's clearly going to be another empire there or rich lands or something. Go down there. I will give you funding, actually. You know, you're my business partner. I'll put more money into your enterprise. You can go off to Chile and carve out your own empire there, which will end up being called New Toledo. Do you think he knows that there's nothing there?
基本上，那里显然会有另一个帝国或富饶的土地之类的东西。去那里吧。我实际上会给你提供资金。你知道，你是我的商业伙伴。我会投入更多的钱到你的企业中。你可以去智利，在那里开辟你自己的帝国，最终会被称为新托莱多。你认为他知道那里什么都没有吗？
I mean, he's been down in Lima. No, I don't, because it's a long old way. They don't really know what's there, I think. And actually, Amagro ends up marching past the great mine at Potter C, which becomes the most lucrative mine in the world. It doesn't realize it's there. So there was money there if he had found it, but it didn't. But he's going to end up marching across the driest desert
我的意思是，他一直在利马。不，我不这么认为，因为它是一段很长的路。我认为他们真的不知道那里有什么。事实上，阿尔马格罗最终走过了波托西的大矿山，它成为了世界上最赚钱的矿山。他没有意识到它在那里。所以如果他找到了，那里是有钱的，但他没有。但他最终会走过最干燥的沙漠
in the world, isn't he? Yes, exactly. I kind of think Pizarro has some sense of the geography. Maybe. So anyway, Almagros sets off for Chile. He's got 600 Spaniards. And actually, Manko gives him an army of 12,000 men, commanded by the high priest to Vilak-Umu and Manko's brother, Paolu.
在世界上，不是吗？是的，完全正确。我有点认为皮萨罗对地理有一些了解。也许吧。所以无论如何，阿尔马格罗出发前往智利。他有600名西班牙人。事实上，曼科给了他一支12000人的军队，由大祭司维拉克·乌穆和曼科的兄弟保卢指挥。
So off they go to the south. And it's a complete and utter nightmare. They have totally unprepared for climbing up onto the high Andean plateau, the Alteplanol, which is basically Bolivia and northern Chile. They run out of water. They absolutely disgrace themselves this expedition. There's a priest called Christabel de Molina
所以他们向南进发。这是一个彻头彻尾的噩梦。他们完全没有准备好攀登高安第斯高原，即阿尔蒂普拉诺，基本上是玻利维亚和智利北部。他们耗尽了水。这次探险让他们彻底丢脸。有一位名叫克里斯托瓦尔·德·莫利纳的牧师
who is with them and he said, any natives who would not accompany the Spaniards voluntarily were taken along bound in ropes and chains. The Spaniards imprisoned them in very rough prisons every night
和他们在一起，他说，任何不愿自愿陪伴西班牙人的土著都被绑在绳索和锁链中带走。西班牙人每天晚上把他们关在非常粗糙的监狱里
and led them by day, heavily loaded and dying of hunger. So they've got these huge chain gangs. When somebody dies in the chain gang which they do all the time because they're exhausted, they're hungry, thirsty, whatever,
白天带着他们，负重累累，饿得要死。所以他们有这些巨大的苦役犯链条。当链条中的某个人死去时（他们总是这样，因为他们筋疲力尽，又饿又渴，等等），
the Spaniards do something very horrible. They cut the heads off these people who have died, but they leave the bodies still attached to the chain. So as you're trudging along, you're having to kind of drag this corpse. Drag this corpse, which could be in front of you, behind you, in the chain. Both. I mean, it's pretty horrible. They get to Southern Bolivia, and at this point, the high priest, Vilac Umu, who's gone with them, deserts, and he goes back to Kusko. He rushes back to Kusko. He gets to Kusko, and he meets up with Manco, and he says, these people are absolutely. scum. They're behaving terribly badly.
西班牙人做了一些非常可怕的事情。他们砍下这些死者的头，但让身体仍然连接在链条上。所以当你蹒跚前行时，你不得不拖着这具尸体。拖着这具尸体，它可能在你前面，在你后面，在链条里。两者都有。我的意思是，这太可怕了。他们到达了玻利维亚南部，此时，随行的最高祭司维拉克·乌穆逃跑了，他回到了库斯科。他赶回库斯科。他到达库斯科，遇见了曼科，他说，这些人绝对是
You know, we can't live like this. We cannot spend our entire lives in misery and subjection. Let us die for our liberty and for the wives and children whom they continually take from us and abuse. I will say one thing about all these tremendous quotations. Some of these are by people who I
人渣。他们的行为非常恶劣。你知道，我们不能这样生活。我们不能把我们的一生都花在痛苦和屈服中。让我们为我们的自由，为那些他们不断从我们身边夺走并虐待的妻子和孩子而死吧。关于所有这些惊人的引语，我要说一件事。其中一些是由我认为
think had had classical educations. So, if it strikes you as the Inkers are speaking very much like people spoke in our Carthage series, this is probably the explanation. Anyway, Manco summons this great meeting, November 1535. And actually, you know, that speech that you began with, Tom, is very, very, you know, Carthaginian resistance or something, isn't it? However, it was reported to us by a chronicler called Thea Theta de Leon, and he said he had an eyewitness account from a servant called Alimache.
受过古典教育的人说的。所以，如果印加人说话的方式让你觉得很像我们在迦太基系列中人们说话的方式，这可能就是解释。无论如何，曼科召集了这次伟大的会议，1535年11月。而且，你知道，汤姆，你开始时说的那段演讲，非常、非常、你知道，迦太基式的抵抗之类的，不是吗？然而，它是由一位名叫西耶萨·德·莱昂的编年史家向我们报告的，他说他有一个来自名叫阿利马切的仆人的目击者陈述。
Oh, well then. So, it must be true. And he had a recording device. Exactly. It's basically a transcript. Manco said, you know, I've sent for you my kinsman to tell you what I think about these foreigners before it's too late, before more foreigners join them. They're waking up to that then.
哦，那好吧。所以，它一定是真的。而且他有一个录音设备。完全正确。它基本上是一份文字记录。曼科说，你知道，我召集你们，我的亲属，是为了在为时已晚之前，在更多的外国人加入他们之前，告诉你们我对这些外国人的看法。他们意识到这一点了。
They are. They are. Because that's what Francisco Pizarro is doing on the coast at Lima. He's basically preparing a base for people to arrive as they sail down the Pacific. Samanka runs through all the bullet points that you did at the beginning of the episode. Spaniards lost for gold, treatments of women, poor behavior. And then the stirring final line will strive with all. I might kill them, or we will die in the attempt.
他们是。他们是。因为这就是弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗在海岸利马所做的事情。他基本上是在为人们在太平洋航行时到达这里准备一个基地。所以曼科浏览了你在剧集开始时所做的所有要点。西班牙人对黄金的渴望，对妇女的对待，糟糕的行为。然后是那句激动人心的最后一行：我们将竭尽全力杀死他们，或者我们将在尝试中死去。
And I suppose what you would say if you were being hostile to Manco is, if only he'd realized this a year earlier, he could have teamed up with Attawalp as old generals. So he could have had Rumi Niawi with his drum, his human drum on his side. But alas, he tried to use the Spaniards against them, and so he's going to be doing this on his own. So that night, after this meeting, Manco and his entourage slip out of Kusko under cover of darkness to launch the resistance. But they are betrayed because one of their servants was a spy for the Pizarro brothers. As soon as Manko has gone, this servant rushes off to Juan and Gonzalo Pizarro
我想如果你对曼科怀有敌意，你会说，如果他早一年意识到这一点，他本可以与阿塔瓦尔帕的老将军们联手。所以他本可以有鲁米·尼亚维带着他的鼓，他的人皮鼓站在他这一边。但唉，他试图利用西班牙人来对付他们，所以他将不得不独自完成这一切。所以那天晚上，会议结束后，曼科和他的随从在夜幕掩护下溜出库斯科，发动抵抗。但他们被出卖了，因为他们的一名仆人是皮萨罗兄弟的间谍。曼科一走，这名仆人就冲向胡安和贡萨洛·皮萨罗
and he says, you know, Manko's gone. So they ride off in pursuit and they find on the road south out of Cusco loads of Inca's. And they say, were you with Manko? Where did Manko go? And they what the Inca's don't answer. So they seized one of them, and according to the Spanish chroniclers, tortured him astutely until he gave a great shout, saying the Inca was not going that way. How do you torture someone astutely? Well, Tom, I mean, if you know, you know.
他说，你知道，曼科走了。所以他们骑马追赶，在库斯科南下的路上发现了许多印加人。他们说，你们和曼科在一起吗？曼科去哪了？印加人没有回答。所以他们抓住了其中一个，根据西班牙编年史家的说法，对他进行了精明的折磨，直到他大喊一声，说印加人没有走那条路。你怎么能精明地折磨一个人？嗯，汤姆，我的意思是，如果你知道，你就知道。
You know. Yeah. So they've tortured him astutely with this rope, and the guy finally shouts out, he's not going that way. Well, actually, Banco has gone that way. They find him hiding in some reeds at the end of the valley. Now they drag Manco back.
你知道。是的。所以他们用这根绳子精明地折磨他，那家伙终于大喊，他没有走那条路。好吧，实际上，曼科走了那条路。他们在山谷尽头的一些芦苇丛中发现了他。现在他们把曼科拖了回来。
Remember Manco is the Sapa Inca, the son of the sun. And this shows the extent to which the Spanish respect has completely degenerated into total contempt. Because they drag him back, they throw him into prison with a chain around his neck and shackles on his feet. And then they treat him very badly. So these are from Spanish sources, right? This is Diego Del Magro's son. They urinated and spat in his face. They struck and beat him.
记住曼科是萨帕·印加，太阳之子。这表明西班牙人的尊重已经完全退化为彻底的蔑视。因为他们把他拖回来，把他扔进监狱，脖子上套着链子，脚上戴着镣铐。然后他们对他非常不好。所以这些来自西班牙资料，对吧？这是迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗的儿子。他们在他脸上撒尿和吐口水。他们殴打他。
They called him a dog. They kept him with a chain around his neck. neck in a public place where people passed. This is that priest, Christobald de Molina. They stole everything he had, leaving him nothing. They kept him in prison for many days, guarded day and night. They treated him very, very disgracefully, urinating on him and sleeping with his wives, and he was deeply distressed. The whole urinating on him thing, I mean, that seems clearly did happen, because the way they keep harping on about it. Precisely, and it's not a detail that you often see in a 16th century accounts. They also do a terrible thing where they burn his eyelashes
他们叫他狗。他们让他脖子上套着链子，在人们经过的公共场所。这就是那位牧师，克里斯托瓦尔·德·莫利纳。他们偷走了他所有的一切，什么都没给他留下。他们把他关在监狱里许多天，日夜看守。他们对他非常、非常不光彩地对待，在他身上撒尿，和他的妻子们睡觉，他非常痛苦。整个在他身上撒尿的事情，我的意思是，那显然确实发生了，因为他们一直喋喋不休地谈论它。正是如此，而且这不是你在16世纪的记载中经常看到的细节。他们还做了一件可怕的事情，用蜡烛烧他的睫毛
with a candle, shouting at him, dog, give us gold. If not, you will be burned. So basically, they're just torturing him. I mean, they're tormenting and torturing him. Astutely. The word obviously spreads because there are now uprisings across the countryside. There were reports coming in that when Spaniards go out to their estates to collect their tribute, the locals are rising up and attacking them. About 30 Spaniards in total are killed. Gonzalo and Juan Pizarro ride out to the city to exact really, horrendous reprisals. There's lots of burning people alive. There's lots of cutting people's arms and legs off, all of this kind of thing. And then in January 1536, there's a little bit of a change
对他大喊，狗，给我们黄金。如果不给，你就会被烧死。所以基本上，他们只是在折磨他。我的意思是，他们在折磨和拷打他。精明地。这个消息显然传开了，因为现在全国各地都有起义。有报告说，当西班牙人去他们的地产征收贡品时，当地人正在起义并攻击他们。总共约有30名西班牙人被杀。贡萨洛和胡安·皮萨罗骑马出城进行非常可怕的报复。有很多活活烧死人的事情。有很多砍掉人们手臂和腿的事情，所有这些事情。然后在1536年1月，发生了一点变化
because their older brother, Hernando, returns from Spain. Now, you may remember that Pizarro had sent Hernando to Spain to take the gold to the court to show Charles V. And Hernando had done this, and it was very successful, and it had been very good for the Pizarro faction. Anando has now returned. He had previously, if you remember, been quite Pally with Atta Walper. And he does seem to have been a little bit more sympathetic
因为他们的哥哥埃尔南多从西班牙回来了。现在，你可能记得皮萨罗派埃尔南多去西班牙把黄金带到宫廷给查理五世看。埃尔南多做到了，非常成功，这对皮萨罗派系非常好。埃尔南多现在回来了。如果你记得的话，他以前和阿塔瓦尔帕相当友好。而且他似乎确实比他行为粗鲁的兄弟们更同情
to the locals than his boorishly behaved brothers. So he arrives in Kusko and he says, what's all this? You know, we need to change the record a bit. So he goes to Simanko, who's recently been released. He treats him a great courtesy.
当地人。所以他到达库斯科，他说，这是怎么回事？你知道，我们需要稍微改变一下记录。所以他去找曼科，他最近刚被释放。他对他表现出极大的礼貌。
He says, you know, I've been speaking to Charles V. Charles VIII. Charles V really respects you. Things have got a little bit out of hand and, you know, I'm sorry. that. We can start again. Unfortunately, if you have any self-respect as a person, I feel like if you've been urinated on, if somebody has slept with your wives, there's no coming back from that,
他说，你知道，我和查理五世谈过。查理五世真的很尊重你。事情有点失控了，你知道，我很抱歉。那。我们可以重新开始。不幸的是，如果你作为一个人的自尊心，我觉得如果你被撒尿，如果有人和你的妻子睡觉，那是没有回头路的。
really, is there? You can't start again. You can't let, you know, let bygones be bygones. So Mancoe in the early months of 5036 starts plotting with his brother, the high priest, Vilak, Umu. And they make their plans by the end of the rainy season, which is late March, the word has gone out, will make weapons in secret, get people to stop. food and supplies. And then in April, they send messages out across the empire with their lovely knotted strings, the kibus. They say, this is on.
真的吗，是这样吗？你无法重新开始。你不能让往事随风。因此，曼科在5036年的头几个月开始与他的兄弟，大祭司维拉克·乌穆密谋。他们在雨季结束时，也就是三月下旬，制定了计划，消息传了出去，他们将秘密制造武器，让人们停止提供食物和补给。然后在四月，他们用他们精美的结绳记事——奇普，向整个帝国发送了消息。他们说，行动开始了。
We're going to do this. We can have a massive uprising. The muster point will be a place called Lares in the Yucay Valley, the sacred valley, 15 miles north of Kusko. And the question is, how is Manco? Remember, when you tried to get out of the city last time, there was action with astute use of ropes. Yeah. How is he going to get out this time?
我们要干这一票。我们要发动一场大规模的起义。集结地点将是库斯科以北15英里的圣谷中的拉雷斯。问题是，曼科该怎么办？还记得上次他试图逃出城时，那是靠巧妙地利用绳子才脱身的。是的，这次他要怎么出去呢？
He has a very clever wheeze. He uses the Spanish greed against them. He goes to Anando and he says, My brother, the high priest, Vilaq Umu, and I would like to go to a religious festival in the Sacred Valley. And actually, if you let us go, they've got a giant golden statue of my father, Huenna Kappak. And I'd love you to have it.
他有一个非常聪明的诡计。他利用西班牙人的贪婪来对付他们。他去找埃尔南多说，我的兄弟，大祭司维拉克·乌穆和我，想去圣谷参加一个宗教节日。实际上，如果你让我们走，他们那里有一尊我父亲瓦伊纳·卡帕克的巨大金像。我很乐意把它送给你。
And And Ando says, oh, well, in that case, why haven't you left already? My goodness, of course you can go. So on the Wednesday before Easter, after Mass, Manco and Villakuma go out the city. Now, on the way, they meet another conquistador who's very suspicious. Where are you going off to? And Manco says, oh, well, we've found there's some hidden gold in those hills, and we're going to go and get it. Oh, well, then.
埃尔南多说，哦，既然这样，那你为什么还不走呢？天哪，你当然可以去。于是，在复活节前的星期三，弥撒结束后，曼科和维拉克·乌穆走出了城。现在，在路上，他们遇到了另一位非常多疑的征服者。你们要去哪儿？曼科说，哦，我们在那些山里发现了一些隐藏的黄金，我们要去把它取回来。哦，那好吧。
Good luck. So they get to Lares, and all the big incochiefs are there. And there are loads more of these rousing speeches. They all swear an oath. We'll drive the Spaniards out of our country or die in the attempt. And actually Manko is delighted to discover that his local sort of chiefs and commanders and bigwigs have done him a great job. They have gathered about a hundred thousand people and they have somehow armed them and fed them. These people have come from the land.
祝你们好运。于是他们到达了拉雷斯，所有印加的大酋长都在那里。还有更多激动人心的演讲。他们都发了誓。我们要把西班牙人赶出我们的国家，否则就死在尝试中。事实上，曼科很高兴地发现，他当地的酋长、指挥官和权贵们干得非常出色。他们聚集了大约十万人，并且以某种方式武装并喂养了他们。这些人来自这片土地。
So they're peasants and farmers and stuff, but they've been giving clubs and whatnot. And slings, right? Slings, exactly. And they are outside the capital. And as John Hemings says in his brilliant book, This is the last great tribute to the Inca's genius for organisation. It was a very top-down, very collectivist kind of empire, and this is their last great effort at mobilising the people.
所以他们是农民和农夫之类的，但他们被分发了棍棒之类的东西。还有投石索，对吧？没错，就是投石索。他们就在首都外面。正如约翰·赫明在他那本出色的书中写道，这是印加人组织天才的最后一次伟大致敬。这是一个非常自上而下、非常集体主义的帝国，这是他们动员人民的最后一次伟大努力。
So by Easter Saturday, they are moving onto the slopes around Kusco, these giant, giant numbers of people. And the Spaniards look out, one of them says, there were so many troops they covered all the fields. By day, they look like a black carpet covering everything for half a league, the city and by night there were so many campfires that the land like a clear sky filled with stars. On Easter Saturday, Enando gets word. He can't believe this. You know, what idiots his brothers were to let him down and provoke this uprising. And he calls the Spaniards of Kusko to a meeting
到了复活节星期六，他们正向库斯科周围的山坡移动，这些数量庞大的人群。西班牙人向外看，其中一个人说，军队多到覆盖了所有的田野。白天，他们看起来像一块覆盖了半里格城市范围的黑色地毯，晚上，营火多到让大地像布满星星的晴空。复活节星期六，埃尔南多得到了消息。他简直不敢相信。你知道，他的兄弟们让他失望并引发这场起义是多么愚蠢。他召集库斯科的西班牙人开会
and he says, well, we're just going to have to resist. You know, we're not going to give in to this. But there's only about 200 Spaniards maximum in the city and they've got 500 native auxiliary So these are ethnic groups who don't like the Inca's. They're caniari and the Chachapoya. But they're against maybe 100,000 people. I mean, these are not good odds. Anando orders, he says,
他说，好吧，我们只能抵抗了。你知道，我们不会屈服于此。但城里最多只有200名西班牙人，他们有500名土著辅助部队，也就是那些不喜欢印加人的族群。他们是卡尼亚里人和查查波亚人。但他们面对的是大约10万人。我的意思是，这胜算不大。埃尔南多下令，他说，
well, the Inca's always frightened of our cavalry. We'll send out our horses. But for the first time, the Inkers are there in such numbers that the horses can't manoeuvre in the crush. So they're basically pushed back into the city and the Inca's advance and advance until they're camped right outside the walls.
好吧，印加人总是害怕我们的骑兵。我们派出我们的马匹。但这是第一次，印加人数量如此之多，以至于马匹在拥挤中无法机动。所以他们基本上被推回了城里，印加人不断推进，直到他们在城墙外扎营。
And then we're told they taunted the Spaniards, and I quote, raising their bare legs at them to show how much they despised them. So what's going on there? Well, if you've ever met a Peruvian and he's bared his legs at you, you know. Oh, that's what they were doing. Yeah, exactly. You can't pretend that's never happened to you. And so, at dawn on the 6th of May, Manco orders the assault. And it is a tremendous scene.
然后我们被告知他们嘲弄了西班牙人，我引用一下，抬起他们的裸腿向他们展示他们是多么鄙视他们。那到底是怎么回事？好吧，如果你见过秘鲁人，他向你露出腿，你就知道了。哦，他们就是这么做的。是的，完全正确。你不能假装那从未发生在你身上。于是，在5月6日的黎明，曼科下令进攻。这是一个惊人的场面。
Very Hollywood. The sun rises. And as it does so, the Inca's charged down. the hillsides, they smash through the Spanish defences, they fight their way into the narrow alleys that lead into the city, they break through the Spanish barricades and palisades, they drive back in the garrison, and they fight their way into the central square. And all the time, the Inkers have this new weapon, a secret weapon. They'd always, you mentioned their slings, they'd always relied very heavily on their slingshots, but now they've been heating the stones and their campfires,
非常像好莱坞电影。太阳升起。随着太阳升起，印加人冲下山坡，他们粉碎了西班牙人的防御，杀入通往城市的狭窄小巷，突破了西班牙人的路障和栅栏，击退了守军，并杀入了中央广场。一直以来，印加人都有这种新武器，一种秘密武器。他们一直，你提到了他们的投石索，他们一直非常依赖他们的投石索，但现在他们一直在营火中加热石头，
they've been wrapping them in kind of cotton wool, and then they send them full. flying onto the thatched roofs of Kusko. And a Spanish chronicle says, there was a strong wind that day. And as the roofs of the houses were thatch, it seemed at one moment as if the city were one great sheet of flame. So these huge black clouds of smoke start rising above the city. The Spanish from total chaos, they can't breathe through the smoke. They can't hear their men's orders because of the din from the attackers, the roar of the fires. And they're being driven further and further and further back. And as Manco's son, Tito Kuzzi, wrote, they feared that these were to be the last moments of their lives. They could see no hope of relief, and they did not know what to do.
他们把石头用棉花之类的东西包起来，然后把它们全速射向库斯科的茅草屋顶。一位西班牙编年史家说，那天风很大。由于房屋的屋顶是茅草做的，那一刻城市看起来就像一片巨大的火焰。所以这些巨大的黑烟云开始在城市上空升起。西班牙人陷入了彻底的混乱，他们无法透过烟雾呼吸。由于攻击者的喧嚣和火灾的轰鸣，他们听不到士兵的命令。他们被一步步逼退。正如曼科的儿子蒂托·库西所写，他们担心这是他们生命的最后时刻。他们看不到任何救援的希望，也不知道该怎么办。
My goodness. So is this the end of Spanish rule in Peru? Is this the restoration of the Incan Empire? Only one way to find out, and that is to join us again after a break. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, Dominic history is full of examples of people who are promised the world and then got very badly let down. Can you think of a particular example? I can think of a couple of examples, Tom. So we've just been recording a series about the fall of the Incas. And Francisco Pizarro, who was the Spanish conquister or in charge.
天哪。那么这是西班牙在秘鲁统治的终结吗？这是印加帝国的复辟吗？只有一个办法可以知道，那就是休息后回来加入我们。本集由先锋集团赞助。现在，多米尼克，历史上充满了被承诺世界然后又被严重辜负的人的例子。你能想到一个具体的例子吗？汤姆，我能想到几个例子。我们刚刚录制了一个关于印加帝国衰落的系列节目。而弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗，那位负责的西班牙征服者。
First of all, he betrayed his business partner Diego de A Magro. And then, shockingly, he betrayed the Inca Emperor. Attawalpa. Well, Dominic, can I ask you a question? Had Atta Walper been in the hands of Vanguard, do you think that Vanguard would have let him down? No, the thing about Vanguard, Vanguard was founded on one core principle and that principle is putting investors first. Tom, for more than 50 years, Vanguard have been delivering on that promise for millions of clients worldwide. And do you know what's brilliant? You too can open an ICER or a self-invested personal pension and you can choose investments yourself or you can let Vanguard choose and manage them for you. So search a Vanguard
首先，他背叛了他的商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗。然后，令人震惊的是，他背叛了印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕。好吧，多米尼克，我可以问你一个问题吗？如果阿塔瓦尔帕在先锋集团手中，你认为先锋集团会辜负他吗？不，关于先锋集团，先锋集团建立在一个核心原则之上，那个原则就是把投资者放在第一位。汤姆，50多年来，先锋集团一直在为全球数百万客户兑现这一承诺。你知道什么很棒吗？你也可以开设一个个人储蓄账户或个人养老金，你可以自己选择投资，或者你可以让先锋集团为你选择和管理它们。所以搜索先锋集团
investor to find out more. When investing, your capital is at risk and tax rules apply. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest is history. It is May 1536 and the troops of Manco, the Incan Emperor, have launched their assault on Kusco where a very small number of Spaniards, fewer than 200 are trapped. The city is burning. Dominic, is this the end for Anando Pizarro and his men? Well, it's definitely the end for a particular version of Kusko. So Kusko, a beautiful city, but now as John Heming says, stripped for Atteralpa's ransom, ransacked by Spanish looters, and it's now being burned by its own people. And the Spanish have been pushed right back into the central square. They, as you say, they are trapped, and this really is their darkest hour.
投资者以了解更多信息。投资时，你的资本面临风险，且适用税收规则。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在是1536年5月，印加皇帝曼科的军队已经对库斯科发动了进攻，不到200名西班牙人被困在那里。城市正在燃烧。多米尼克，这是埃尔南多·皮萨罗和他部下的末日吗？好吧，这绝对是库斯科某个特定版本的终结。所以库斯科，一座美丽的城市，但现在正如约翰·赫明所说，为了阿塔瓦尔帕的赎金被剥削，被西班牙掠夺者洗劫，现在又被它自己的人民烧毁。西班牙人被推回了中央广场。正如你所说，他们被困住了，这确实是他们最黑暗的时刻。
One side of the square, though, is not burning because it's relatively open. There aren't many buildings there. So this is their kind of escape from the smoke and the flames. And they take refuge in two great buildings at the eastern end of the square. Amazingly, the Inca's don't manage, these are two buildings that the Inca's don't manage to set fire to. Now, later on, some Spanish writers said this was because of divine intervention. It's the Virgin. The Virgin Mary in a blue cloak intervened to put out the fires.
不过，广场的一侧没有燃烧，因为它相对开阔。那里没有多少建筑物。所以这是他们逃离烟雾和火焰的地方。他们在广场东端的两座大楼里避难。令人惊讶的是，印加人没能，这两座建筑印加人没能放火烧掉。后来，一些西班牙作家说这是因为神圣的干预。是圣母。穿着蓝色斗篷的圣母玛利亚干预并扑灭了大火。
She had a load of white blankets. So she appeared through these white blankets over the flames. And this saved the Spaniards. I'm sorry to say, I don't want to disappoint our Catholic listeners, but I believe this is a later invention at least 100 years later. Didn't Manco Inca's son say that the Spaniards had placed African slaves on the roofs with buckets of water? Yeah, so that's perfectly plausible. slightly less dramatic, but probably, as you say, more plausible.
她有一堆白毯子。所以她出现并把这些白毯子扔在火焰上。这救了西班牙人。我很抱歉，我不想让我们的天主教听众失望，但我相信这是后来的发明，至少是100年后的事。曼科印加的儿子不是说西班牙人把非洲奴隶放在屋顶上，拿着水桶吗？是的，这完全说得通。虽然没那么戏剧性，但正如你所说，可能更可信。
It's a good point that you make there because actually throughout this story, there are almost certainly some African slaves on hand. We know that the Spanish had started to import people. They're coming down from Central America. And you don't really get many glimpses of them in the sources, but I think you have to imagine that they're always there. So there's luck, there's brutal hand-to-hand fighting, and basically by nightfall, the pattern is set.
你指出的这一点很好，因为实际上在整个故事中，几乎肯定有一些非洲奴隶在场。我们知道西班牙人已经开始进口人口。他们从中美洲下来。你在资料中看不到太多关于他们的片段，但我认为你必须想象他们一直都在那里。所以有运气，有残酷的肉搏战，基本上到了夜幕降临，模式就定下来了。
The Spaniards are hemmed into the small corner of Cusco City. centre. The Inca's are encamped around them. It feels very like the siege of Tenochtitlan, for people who remember our series about the fall of the Aztecs. And for the next six days or so, the Spanish fight, days, as one writer puts it, strenuous toil and danger, slowly sort of pushing out from their little redoubt. There are incas still who are siding with them, aren't there, even in Cusco. So it's not like they are completely isolated. No. There is an element of an Incan civil war going on at the same time. The Tumblides, again, very hard to glimpse in the sources,
西班牙人被困在库斯科市中心的一个小角落里。印加人驻扎在他们周围。这感觉非常像特诺奇蒂特兰之围，对于记得我们关于阿兹特克衰落系列节目的听众来说。在接下来的六天左右，西班牙人战斗，正如一位作家所说，艰苦的劳作和危险，慢慢地从他们的小堡垒中推出来。仍然有印加人站在他们一边，不是吗，即使在库斯科。所以他们并不是完全孤立的。不。同时发生着一场印加内战。坦布利德人，同样，很难在资料中看到，
but we are told that, for example, some of Manco's own brothers side with the Spaniards. So throughout this whole story, I mean, you're dead right to point this out. Throughout this whole story, it's not a simple matter of Spaniards versus Inca's. It is Spaniards and Inca's and other, you know, indigenous peoples fighting Inca's and other indigenous. Indigenous groups. It's just a massive punch-up.
但我们被告知，例如，曼科自己的一些兄弟站在西班牙人一边。所以在这个整个故事中，我的意思是，你指出这一点是非常正确的。在这个整个故事中，这不仅仅是西班牙人对阵印加人的简单问题。这是西班牙人和印加人以及其他，你知道，土著民族在与印加人和其他土著民族战斗。土著群体。这简直是一场大规模的混战。
Basically, yes. Everyone's fighting each other. They are all fighting each other. Some of the Spaniards say to Anando, you know, the odds are massively against us. We should break out of the city and make for the coast. Anando has the excellent line. He says, no, we should fight back. Better to die fighting than to perish here like hogs.
基本上，是的。每个人都在互相打斗。他们都在互相打斗。一些西班牙人对埃尔南多说，你知道，胜算对我们非常不利。我们应该突围出城，前往海岸。埃尔南多有一句精彩的台词。他说，不，我们应该反击。与其像猪一样死在这里，不如战死。
Like hogs. Yeah, I think that's an American translator, isn't it? So, Anando says, listen, we're kind of sitting ducks here because the Inkers have taken up a position in the citadel of Saxe-Hu-Mann, which is on this kind of rock spur that overlooks the city centre, right? And this fortress, this citadel had been built by Pachicuti, the legendary sort of great Inca imperialist. It's a fortress, it's also a temple, it's a huge storehouse, it's this key strategic location. And Spanish accounts of the citadel of Saxe-Huhrman said that it had massive stone walls, it had these huge towers, it had a labyrinth of tunnels.
像猪一样。是的，我想那是一个美国翻译，不是吗？所以，埃尔南多说，听着，我们在这里就像坐以待毙，因为印加人已经在萨克塞瓦曼的城堡占据了位置，它就在俯瞰市中心的岩石支线上，对吧？这座堡垒，这座城堡是由帕查库蒂建造的，他是传说中伟大的印加帝国主义者。它是一座堡垒，也是一座寺庙，它是一个巨大的仓库，它是这个关键的战略位置。西班牙关于萨克塞瓦曼城堡的记载说，它有巨大的石墙，有这些巨大的塔楼，有一个隧道迷宫。
The Spanish writer Garthelaso de la Vega said, it's one of the wonders of the world. There was nothing like it in Spain and Europe. It was so vast that devil himself must have helped to build it. Actually, it was built by forced labour. And Anando says, right, we have to capture this back. They can rain down missiles on us from this citadel. So the plan is that his brother Juan will lead the attack with 50 horsemen.
西班牙作家加尔西拉索·德·拉·维加说，它是世界奇迹之一。在西班牙和欧洲没有类似的东西。它太广阔了，魔鬼本人一定帮忙建造了它。实际上，它是通过强迫劳动建造的。埃尔南多说，好吧，我们必须把它夺回来。他们可以从这座城堡向我们倾泻导弹。所以计划是他兄弟胡安将带领50名骑兵发动进攻。
they'll burst through the enemy lines, they'll charge up the hill and capture the citadel. It's a very kind of helms-deep plan, and there's a very helms-deep scene to kick it all off. So a later Incasaw says, the Spaniards spent the whole of that night on their knees with their hands clasped in prayer. Even those on guard in the square did the same, as did many Indians who were on their side. On the following morning at dawn, they emerged from the church and mounted their horses. suddenly they put spur to their horses and at full gallop broke through the enemy
他们将冲破敌人的防线，冲上山坡并占领城堡。这是一个非常类似“圣盔谷”的计划，而且有一个非常类似“圣盔谷”的场景来开启这一切。所以后来的印加人说，西班牙人整晚都跪在地上，双手合十祈祷。即使是广场上的守卫也做了同样的事，站在他们一边的许多印第安人也是如此。第二天黎明，他们走出教堂，骑上马。突然，他们策马奔腾，全速冲破敌人
and charged up the hillside at breakneck speed. So very exciting. Stones and missiles are kind of raining down on them but they zigzag up the hill. They reach the terraces. They turn right at a village on the top of the hill and they finally end up in the parade ground
并以极快的速度冲上山坡。所以非常令人兴奋。石头和导弹像雨点般落在他们身上，但他们呈之字形上山。他们到达了梯田。他们在山顶的一个村庄右转，最后到达了阅兵场
in front of the citadel. And here, Inkers have put up barricades but Juan Pizarro and his brother Gonzalo lead the horsemen in charge after charge. Some of the horses are wounded some of the Spaniards are thrown from the horses, but they managed to break through the barricades and get all the way to the fortress gate.
在城堡前面。在这里，印加人设置了路障，但胡安·皮萨罗和他的兄弟贡萨洛带领骑兵一次又一次地冲锋。一些马匹受伤了，一些西班牙人被从马上摔了下来，但他们设法突破了路障，一直到达了堡垒大门。
Now, it's now late afternoon and they're knackered. The Inca's raiding down these kind of javelins and slingstones and stuff. Juan's page boy is killed by this huge stone. Juan Pizarro himself had been hit the day before by a slingshot missile and his face was so swollen that he couldn't wear his helmet. Oh dear, unwise. But he says to the Spaniards One more attack before nightfall
现在，已经是深夜了，他们筋疲力尽。印加人倾泻着这些标枪和投石索石头之类的东西。胡安的侍从被这块巨大的石头砸死了。胡安·皮萨罗本人前一天被投石索击中，他的脸肿得连头盔都戴不上。哦，亲爱的，不明智。但他对西班牙人说，天黑前再进攻一次
That's what it takes And they spur their horses They race for the gate The missiles are raining down again And then a massive stone Smacks into Juan Pizarro's head Oh my God So like an egg, a boiled egg being smashed
这就是所需要的。他们策马奔腾。他们冲向大门。导弹再次像雨点般落下。然后一块巨大的石头砸在胡安·皮萨罗的头上。哦，我的上帝。就像一个煮熟的鸡蛋被砸碎一样
Exactly He totters, he falls off his horse He's clearly hideously wounded The Spanish break off their charge They rush to his side And they carry him down the hill to Cusco. So he clings to life overnight
完全正确。他摇摇晃晃，从马上摔了下来。他显然受了重伤。西班牙人停止了冲锋。他们冲到他身边，把他抬下山送到库斯科。所以他彻夜挣扎求生
and he dictates her will and he says, I leave all my plunder to my brother Gonzalo. He leaves some money to religious bequest. He leaves some money to the poor. But now he really lets himself down. You may remember he had locked up this young girl who he was sleeping with, who was a princess. And he said, I live nothing to her.
他口述了遗嘱，他说，我把我所有的战利品留给我的兄弟贡萨洛。他留了一些钱给宗教遗赠。他留了一些钱给穷人。但现在他真的让自己失望了。你可能记得他关押了这个他与之同床的年轻女孩，她是一位公主。他说，我什么都不留给她。
He said this. What a bastard to say this. I live nothing to her. He called her an Indian woman who has given birth to a girl whom I do not recognise as my daughter. As you say, an absolute bastard to the end. Yeah, and then he died.
他说了这话。说这话真是个混蛋。我什么都不留给她。他称她为一个印第安女人，生下了一个我不承认是我女儿的女孩。正如你所说，直到最后都是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。是的，然后他就死了。
I mean, so unnecessary. Yeah. But he's a bad advert for Spain, I think. So the next day, Juan's devastated brother, Gonzalo, leads another assault. Great drama. Everyone was shouting and they were all entangled together,
我的意思是，太没必要了。是的。但他对西班牙来说是个糟糕的广告，我想。所以第二天，胡安悲痛欲绝的兄弟贡萨洛发动了另一次进攻。伟大的戏剧。每个人都在大喊大叫，他们都纠缠在一起，
fighting for the hilltop. It looked as though the whole world was up there grappling in close combat. And as nights falling, Anando joins the assault, he's spent the day making scaling ladders. Again, the kind of technology that the Inca's don't really have, but the Spanish, of course, are used to from their fighting in the old world. And under this hail of stones, the Spanish start to scale the outer walls. Again, it is very helms deep. And then there's this ferocious hand-to-hand fighting as they drive the Inca's back to the inner Citadel.
为山顶而战。看起来好像全世界都在上面进行近身肉搏。随着夜幕降临，埃尔南多加入了进攻，他花了一天时间制作云梯。同样，这是印加人并不真正拥有的技术，但西班牙人当然从他们在旧世界的战斗中习惯了这一点。在石雨中，西班牙人开始攀爬外墙。同样，这非常像圣盔谷。然后是残酷的肉搏战，他们把印加人赶回了内城堡。
The fighting goes on for the next two days. The commander of the Citadel was a man called Titouci Gualpa, and he had sworn to fight to the death. He's hit twice by Spanish arrows, but it doesn't deter him. He strides around, we're told, like a lion, from side to side of the tower. He repulsed any Spaniards who tried to mount with scaling ladders.
战斗持续了接下来的两天。城堡的指挥官是一个叫蒂托·库西·瓜尔帕的人，他发誓要战斗到死。他被西班牙箭射中两次，但这并没有阻止他。我们被告知，他像狮子一样在塔楼的两侧走来走去。他击退了任何试图用云梯攀爬的西班牙人。
He killed any Indians who tried to surrender. He smashed their heads with the battle axe he was carrying and hurled them from the top of the tower. So basically like one of Stalin's commissars or something, the Second World War. Basically, if you falter, he'll smash it over there with an axe. I was thinking more like Gimli. Gimli doesn't hit people on the head from his own side, though, and throw them off the tower. Anyway, Gimmy doesn't do this. The Spanish start to throw in their own native auxiliaries. This goes back to your point, Tom, about them having native support.
他杀死了任何试图投降的印第安人。他用他携带的战斧砸碎了他们的头，并把他们从塔顶扔了下去。所以基本上就像斯大林的政委之类的，第二次世界大战。基本上，如果你动摇，他就会用斧头砸碎它。我当时想的是更像吉姆利。不过，吉姆利不会打自己人，也不会把他们从塔上扔下去。无论如何，吉姆利不会这样做。西班牙人开始投入他们自己的土著辅助部队。这回到了你的观点，汤姆，关于他们有土著支持。
Some of them are led by Manko's own brothers, which seems mad. And at last, this guy, Tito Cousi, Gualpa, realizes that the fortress is lost. He throws his weapons down onto the Spanish, and then we're told, I mean, it's a strange choice actually in the last moment. He grabbed handfuls of earth, stuffed them into his mouth and scoured his face in anguish. Then he covered his head with his cloak and he leaped to his death from the top of the fortress in fulfillment of his pledge to the Inca. So the fortress is lost. And And And those men rampaged through. They round up 1,500 people and they put them all to the sword. So now we're at the end of May and the siege has been going, what for a month or two
其中一些由曼科自己的兄弟领导，这看起来很疯狂。终于，这个叫蒂托·库西·瓜尔帕的人意识到堡垒已经失守了。他把武器扔向西班牙人，然后我们被告知，我的意思是，在最后一刻这实际上是一个奇怪的选择。他抓起一把泥土，塞进嘴里，痛苦地擦着脸。然后他用斗篷盖住头，从堡垒顶上跳下，以履行他对印加人的誓言。所以堡垒失守了。埃尔南多的人横冲直撞。他们围捕了1500人，并将他们全部处死。所以现在我们到了五月底，围攻已经持续了，什么，一两个月了
and there's a definite sense that the initial momentum has been lost. We're told that with the fall of the citadel Inca morale begins to ebb. Manco says to his generals, you've let me down. You know, there were so many of you and so few of them and yet again they've eluded your grasp.
有一种明确的感觉，最初的势头已经丧失。我们被告知，随着城堡的陷落，印加人的士气开始减弱。曼科对他的将军们说，你们让我失望了。你知道，你们有那么多人，而他们却那么少，然而他们又一次逃脱了你们的掌握。
There are a couple of reasons I think why this is. John Heming says the Spanish always have this technological advantage. The only real department in which the Inca's have parity as he'd it is in projectiles. But projectiles didn't usually kill an armoured Spaniard. And this is a kind of hand-to-hand bloody fight to the death. And if you've got a steel sword, that can make all the difference. And the other thing is what the point you made, the native allies. They're always there.
我认为这有几个原因。约翰·赫明说西班牙人总是拥有这种技术优势。印加人唯一真正拥有对等地位的部门是投射武器。但投射武器通常杀不死一个全副武装的西班牙人。这是一场血腥的肉搏战。如果你有一把钢剑，那就能产生所有的不同。另一件事是你提到的观点，土著盟友。他们一直都在那里。
We barely glimpsed them in the Spanish sources, but they're always there, you know, between the lines almost. Auxiliaries, servants, armed troops, all of this. But also people have birth as well, aren't there? There are kind of nobleman who come over. Oh yeah, Manco's brothers. In part, I assume, because Manco is destroying their city, I mean, the use of burning slingshot is annihilating a place that is their own. And perhaps they think the Spaniards are the best hope to save it. If you decide the Spaniards are going to win and can't be beaten, then a lot of people will say, well, it's literally pointless to fight on against them. The best thing for our people is to come to an accommodation. You know, we'll save lives, we'll save the city, save our
我们在西班牙资料中几乎看不到他们，但他们一直都在那里，你知道，几乎在战线之间。辅助部队、仆人、武装部队，所有这些。但也有出身高贵的人，不是吗？有那种投靠过来的贵族。哦，是的，曼科的兄弟们。部分原因，我假设，是因为曼科正在摧毁他们的城市，我的意思是，使用燃烧的投石索正在消灭一个他们自己的地方。也许他们认为西班牙人是拯救它的最好希望。如果你认为西班牙人会赢并且无法被打败，那么很多人会说，好吧，继续与他们战斗简直毫无意义。对我们人民来说最好的事情是达成妥协。你知道，我们会拯救生命，我们会拯救城市，拯救我们的
civilization. But this is not the end. The siege drags on for another three months, and it is incredibly fierce. So I'll just give one quote from a Spanish writer, Alonzo Enriquez de Guzman. I can bear witness that this was the most dreadful and cruel war in the world. Between Christians and Moors, so he's talking about the fighting in Spain in the 1490s against the Muslims in the south of Spain. Between Christians and Moors, there is some fellow feeling, and it is in the interests of both sides to spare those they take alive because of their ransoms.
文明。但这并不是结束。围攻又拖了三个月，而且极其激烈。所以我只引用一位西班牙作家阿隆索·恩里克斯·德·古兹曼的话。我可以证明这是世界上最可怕和最残酷的战争。在基督徒和摩尔人之间，所以他在谈论1490年代西班牙南部对抗穆斯林的战斗。在基督徒和摩尔人之间，有一些同情心，双方都有兴趣饶恕他们活捉的人，因为他们的赎金。
But in this Indian war, there is no such feeling. They give each other the cruelest deaths imaginable. So a sense of it being an existential struggle. You know, not governed by the rules that govern fighting in Europe, or the Mediterranean, but something, you know, unbelievably savage in which kind of all restraints are off. And week by week, faced with this, Manco's army is losing momentum.
但在这种印第安战争中，没有这种感觉。他们互相给予想象中最残酷的死亡。所以这是一种存在主义斗争的感觉。你知道，不受欧洲或地中海战斗规则的约束，而是某种，你知道，难以置信的野蛮，在这种情况下，所有的限制都被取消了。随着时间的推移，面对这一切，曼科的军队正在失去势头。
Most of Manco's men are not professional soldiers. They're peasants, their farmers. They've taken their families with them. And by August or so, they're drifting away to go back to their fields. And it's about this point that you get some dramatic news from the coast. So remember that on the coast, at this new city of Lima, Francisco Pizarre has been there all the time.
曼科的大多数人不是职业军人。他们是农民，是农夫。他们带着家人一起。到了八月左右，他们开始散去，回到他们的田地里。就在这一点上，你从海岸得到了一些戏剧性的消息。所以记住在海岸，在这个新城市利马，弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗一直都在那里。
He is sent out a series of relief columns to try and save his brothers. But these had been annihilated as they tried to go over the Andes by one of Manco's best commanders, a guy called Kizzo Yapanqui, who had basically hidden waiting for them in gorges and ravines,
他派出一系列救援纵队试图拯救他的兄弟。但这些纵队在试图翻越安第斯山脉时被曼科最好的指挥官之一，一个叫基佐·尤潘基的人消灭了，他基本上躲在峡谷和沟壑中等待他们，
then hurled down rocks and boulders at them. Really simple, but it worked beautifully. Yeah, so they finally rumbled how to destroy Spanish expeditions. Exactly. Basically, three of these columns were annihilated. 200 horsemen are killed and their severed heads are sent as killed.
然后向他们投掷岩石和巨石。非常简单，但效果非常好。是的，所以他们终于弄清楚了如何摧毁西班牙远征队。完全正确。基本上，这三支纵队都被消灭了。200名骑兵被杀，他们被砍下的头颅被作为战利品送给
gifts to Manco. Do they capture the horses? They don't capture them and ride them, I don't think. I think they kill some of them and the rest of the horses just run away, I think, escape. So Pizarro back in Lima is in a bit of a panic now. He hasn't got any news from Cusco. He doesn't know what's happened to his brothers. He's sending out desperate letters all across the empire, including, actually, to Pedro de Alvarado. The Inca has the city of Cusco besieged, and for five months I've heard nothing. The country is ravaged and the native chiefs have won many victories against us. It causes me such great sorrow that it's consuming my entire life. But there is someone who answers this appeal, isn't there? Who is again a kind of interesting
曼科。他们抓住了马吗？我不认为他们抓住了马并骑着它们。我想他们杀了一些，剩下的马就跑了，我想，逃跑了。所以利马的皮萨罗现在有点恐慌。他没有得到库斯科的任何消息。他不知道他的兄弟们发生了什么事。他正在向整个帝国发送绝望的信件，实际上包括给佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多。印加人围困了库斯科城，五个月来我什么都没听到。国家被蹂躏，土著酋长对我们取得了许多胜利。这让我感到如此巨大的悲伤，以至于它正在消耗我的整个生命。但有人回应了这个呼吁，不是吗？他再次是一个有趣的
illustration of the relationships that can develop between Spaniards and native women. Because this is this woman, Contoaccio, who had been the queen of a native people, taken by Hwana Capac. And she is Pizarro's mother-in-law. and she's one of history's great mother-in-laws and she raises an army of her countrymen and march to Lima to help him. So it can work for both sides. It can, interestingly actually.
说明了西班牙人和土著妇女之间可能发展的关系。因为这就是这个女人，孔托阿乔，她曾是一位土著民族的女王，被瓦伊纳·卡帕克带走。她是皮萨罗的岳母，她是历史上伟大的岳母之一，她召集了一支同胞军队，向利马进军去帮助他。所以这对双方都有效。有趣的是，确实有效。
I mean, although he does get some support, he gets some support from Panama, he gets some native allies, as you rightly say. But actually, across the Spanish empire, the general senses the Pizaros have brought this on themselves. The governors have exploited the Inca. Enando Pizarro, this rebellion, for it is said that he tortured the local chief for his gold and silver.
我的意思是，虽然他确实得到了一些支持，他从巴拿马得到了一些支持，他得到了一些土著盟友，正如你正确指出的那样。但实际上，在整个西班牙帝国，普遍的感觉是皮萨罗家族自找的。总督们剥削了印加人。埃尔南多·皮萨罗，这场叛乱，因为据说他为了黄金和白银折磨了当地酋长。
So even at this point, people are saying, the Pissaros are kind of bad men, they've treated Manco and co very roughly. I mean, they're not wrong, are they? Exactly, they're not wrong. I mean, the idea that the Spanish, the black legend, which is the Spanish are all uniquely cruel and corrupt, is just not true. Even from this stage, lots of Spaniards are saying, the Pizarres are terrible people. And, you know, I've actually felt really sorry for the Inkers.
所以即使在这一点上，人们也在说，皮萨罗家族是坏人，他们对待曼科等人非常粗暴。我的意思是，他们没说错，不是吗？完全正确，他们没说错。我的意思是，西班牙人，黑色传说，即西班牙人都是独特地残酷和腐败的，这根本不是真的。即使从这个阶段开始，许多西班牙人也在说，皮萨罗家族是可怕的人。而且，你知道，我实际上真的为印加人感到难过。
Anyway, things are going to get really tricky for Pizarro now, because this guy keeps Yopanqui, who's crushed his relief columns with boulders, he now descends from the Andes onto the coastal plain and he starts marching on Lima. And in Lima, people become absolutely terrified because very soon Lima's virtually surrounded with Inca troops on the hillside, just as in Kusko. And for five days, they're waiting. And then on the sixth day comes the decisive moment. This guy, Kizzo addresses his men. He says, you know, classic kind of Inca rhetoric. This is the moment to capture the city or to perish in the attempt. I intend to enter the town today and to kill all the Spaniards.
无论如何，皮萨罗现在的情况会变得非常棘手，因为这个用巨石粉碎了他的救援纵队的家伙基佐·尤潘基，他现在从安第斯山脉降临到沿海平原，开始向利马进军。在利马，人们变得非常恐惧，因为很快利马几乎被山坡上的印加军队包围了，就像在库斯科一样。五天来，他们一直在等待。然后在第六天，决定性的时刻到来了。这个家伙，基佐向他的部下发表讲话。他说，你知道，经典的印加修辞。这是占领城市或在尝试中死亡的时刻。我打算今天进入城镇并杀死所有的西班牙人。
And any who accompany me must go on the understanding that if I die, all will die. So the Inca's advance. People said it was an amazing scene. They had these sort of, it's very kingdom of heaven. They've got these kind of banners, kind of waving in the sunshine, an amazing scene. Thousands of Inkers against just two squadrons of Spanish cavalry. Kizo is leading them with a spear on foot. But then as John Heming says,
任何陪伴我的人都必须明白，如果我死了，所有人都会死。所以印加人推进了。人们说这是一个惊人的场面。他们有这些，非常像《天国王朝》。他们有这些在阳光下飘扬的旗帜，一个惊人的场面。成千上万的印加人对抗仅仅两个中队的西班牙骑兵。基佐正带着长矛徒步领导他们。但正如约翰·赫明所说，
for all its splendor and reckless bravery this attack was to prove as futile as that of the French at Agincourt the British at Balaclava or the Confederates at Gettysburg because basically Kizo leads his men and they're on foot and as soon as they were in range the Spanish charge they rush out on their horses and it's flat ground basically they rout Kizo and his men instantly
尽管它辉煌且鲁莽勇敢，但这次进攻被证明和法国人在阿金库尔、英国人在巴拉克拉瓦或南方人在葛底斯堡的进攻一样徒劳，因为基本上基佐带领他的部下，他们是徒步的，一旦他们进入射程，西班牙人就冲锋，他们骑着马冲出来，基本上是平地，他们瞬间击溃了基佐和他的部下
and in the first attack they kill him and they kill 40 of his kind of commanders and chiefs. And Kizzo had said, if I die, all will die. Actually, that's not true. Everybody else just runs away. He's dead. Lima is saved. And now the Spanish can venture out of Lever and vent their fury with some truly hideous reprisals.
在第一次进攻中，他们杀死了他，并杀死了他40名指挥官和酋长。基佐曾说，如果我死了，所有人都会死。实际上，那不是真的。其他人只是跑了。他死了。利马得救了。现在西班牙人可以冒险走出利马，用一些真正可怕的报复来发泄他们的愤怒。
So one of Pizarro's soldiers writes to a friend of his in Seville. We captured alive 100 natives and killed 30. We cut the arms off some of the prisoners and the noses from others and the breasts from the women. then we sent them back to the enemy to show them that they too would submit to the knife. Oh dear. Yeah. So it's only going to get darker, by the way, just to warn you. So Pizarro doesn't know what's been happening to his brothers in Kusko.
所以皮萨罗的一名士兵写信给他在塞维利亚的朋友。我们活捉了100名土著并杀死了30人。我们砍掉了一些囚犯的手臂，砍掉了其他人的鼻子，砍掉了女人的乳房。然后我们把他们送回敌人那里，向他们展示他们也将屈服于刀下。哦，亲爱的。是的。所以情况只会变得更黑暗，顺便提醒你一下。所以皮萨罗不知道他的兄弟们在库斯科发生了什么。
What's been going on there in the meantime? The answer is that they've stabilised the situation. They're still encircled, but they're facing fewer attacks from Manco's men, so much so they've been able to slacken their own guard duty and get some sleep, which is a nice change for their mob. after months of heavy fighting. They occasionally launch raids out of the city. They capture prisoners.
与此同时那里发生了什么？答案是他们稳定了局势。他们仍然被包围，但他们面对曼科部下的攻击减少了，以至于他们能够放松自己的守卫职责并睡个好觉，这对他们的暴徒来说是一个不错的改变。经过几个月的激烈战斗。他们偶尔会从城里发动突袭。他们抓获囚犯。
They bring them back in. They cut off their hands. Then they let them go again as a kind of warning to the others. Yeah, of course they do. They launch raids to get food. So they capture a supply column, Monomanko's supply column that's brought loads of llamas. So they're dining on kind of roasted llama.
他们把他们带回来。他们砍掉他们的手。然后他们再次放走他们作为对其他人的警告。是的，他们当然会这样做。他们发动突袭以获取食物。所以他们抓获了一支补给纵队，曼科的一支带来了大量骆马的补给纵队。所以他们正在享用烤骆马肉。
And by the end of 1536, the whole thing has become a stalemate. The Spaniards can't get out. The Inca's can't get in But on balance this is probably good for the Spaniards Because all the time more ships are coming down the Pacific coast Bringing reinforcements from other Spanish colonies Even from Spain where the court has sent 50 archibusias
到了1536年底，整个事情已经变成了僵局。西班牙人出不去。印加人进不来。但总的来说，这对西班牙人来说可能是有利的。因为一直有更多的船只沿着太平洋海岸下来，从其他西班牙殖民地带来增援。甚至从西班牙，宫廷派出了50名火绳枪手
So gunmen and 50 crossbowmen So they're bringing more new technology And they're coming all the time just as they had in Mexico So the weeks continue The siege goes on And then in April 1537 comes the real game-changing moment. Remember that all this time,
所以枪手和50名弩手。所以他们带来了更多的新技术。他们一直都在来，就像他们在墨西哥所做的那样。所以几周继续过去。围攻继续。然后在1537年4月，真正的游戏规则改变时刻到来了。记住，所有这些时间，
Pizarro's business partner, Diego de El Magro, has been off in Chile, disgracing himself with his chain gangs. He is now coming home. He's very dejected. They've found no gold and silver. They're very miserable. They've basically killed loads of people, but that hasn't made them happy.
皮萨罗的商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗一直在智利，带着他的苦役犯丢尽了脸。他现在要回家了。他非常沮丧。他们没有发现黄金和白银。他们非常悲惨。他们基本上杀死了很多人，但这并没有让他们快乐。
I mean, madly, they marched right past the gigantic silver mine at Pottersy. which at its height, I'll talk about this a little bit, maybe in the next episode, produced 80% of the world's silver. You know, one of the, the Thero Rico, the hill of gold, the hill of silver. They didn't even realize it was there. Anyway, they crossed the Atacama Desert, as you said. What is that, the world's highest desert? No, it's the driest desert. Dryest desert.
我的意思是，疯狂的是，他们直接走过了波托西巨大的银矿，在其鼎盛时期，我会谈谈这个，也许在下一集，生产了世界80%的白银。你知道，其中一个，波托西山，黄金之山，白银之山。他们甚至没有意识到它在那里。无论如何，他们穿过了阿塔卡马沙漠，正如你所说。那是什么，世界上最高的沙漠？不，它是最干燥的沙漠。最干燥的沙漠。
There are places there where there's been no precipitation for centuries. Yeah. Very Alexander the Great, isn't it? Well, we'll probably just cross that, it'd be fine. What's the worse that could happen? They cross this desert, amazing the don't all die. And they discover that they hear Almagro hears, well, this massive war has broken out, and Manco is besieging the city of Cusco.
那里有些地方几个世纪以来没有降水。是的。非常像亚历山大大帝，不是吗？好吧，我们可能只是穿过它，没问题。最坏的情况会是什么？他们穿过了这片沙漠，令人惊讶的是他们没有全部死亡。他们发现，他们听说阿尔马格罗听说，好吧，这场大规模的战争已经爆发，曼科正在围攻库斯科城。
And now Elmacro thinks, well, this is a brilliant opportunity for me. Because basically, if I can get Manco on side, if I can end the war, save New Castile, Charles V will see me as the hero. He, you know, the pizarro is rubbish. He'll see me as the hero of the hour. So he sends Manka this absolutely gushing letter. My well-beloved son and brother. I'm so sorry for the abuse the Christians have done to your person,
现在阿尔马格罗认为，好吧，这对我是个绝佳的机会。因为基本上，如果我能让曼科站在我这边，如果我能结束战争，拯救新卡斯蒂利亚，查理五世会视我为英雄。他，你知道，皮萨罗是垃圾。他会视我为当下的英雄。所以他给曼科发了这封绝对热情的信。我亲爱的儿子和兄弟。我为基督徒对你个人的虐待感到非常抱歉，
the robbery of your property and house and the seizure of your beloved wives. I'm on my way to help you. I won't do anything without your approval. I will never refuse you the friendship I've always felt for you. So in April 1537, Al-Magros army arrives around Cusco. You now have, I mean, this is so George I.R.R. Martin, isn't it? you know have three forces in a standoff. Anando Pizarro in the city and two different armies outside the city,
对你财产和房屋的抢劫，以及对你心爱妻子的掠夺。我正在赶来帮助你。没有你的批准我什么都不会做。我永远不会拒绝我一直对你怀有的友谊。所以1537年4月，阿尔马格罗的军队到达了库斯科周围。你现在有，我的意思是，这太乔治·R·R·马丁了，不是吗？你现在有三股力量在对峙。城里的埃尔南多·皮萨罗和城外的两支不同的军队，
that are Manco and that of Almagro. What's really unclear is how this constellation of forces will play out. So Manco surely knows now that with two Spanish armies, he's not going to drive them all out of Peru. He can't beat two of them. He also knows that Pizaros will not forgive him for this war. Anando in the city, he would love to, the siege to end.
那是曼科和阿尔马格罗的军队。真正不清楚的是这种力量组合将如何发挥作用。所以曼科现在肯定知道，有两支西班牙军队，他不会把他们全部赶出秘鲁。他打不过他们两个。他也知道皮萨罗家族不会因为这场战争原谅他。城里的埃尔南多，他很乐意，围攻结束。
On the other hand, he hates Almagro, and he's got no intention of giving him Kusko. So who do you think he hates more, Manco or Amalgo? Oh, Al-Magro. I would have thought to say. The Spanish hate each other far more than they hate the Inca's.
另一方面，他讨厌阿尔马格罗，他根本没打算把库斯科给他。所以你认为他更恨谁，曼科还是阿尔马格罗？哦，阿尔马格罗。我本以为会这么说。西班牙人互相憎恨的程度远超过他们憎恨印加人。
Yeah, because there's no sense. I mean, Manco's, you know, he's the opposition. He's doing what he should be doing. Because that would be a punchy reversal, wouldn't it? For him suddenly to team up with Manco and wipe out. That would be the real. See, that's the real what-if of history. If Anando Pizarre had teamed up with Manco at that point to attack on Magro.
是的，因为没有意义。我的意思是，曼科，你知道，他是反对派。他正在做他应该做的事。因为那将是一个有力的反转，不是吗？如果他突然与曼科联手并消灭。那将是真正的。看，那是历史真正的假设。如果埃尔南多·皮萨罗当时与曼科联手攻击阿尔马格罗。
But actually Almagro moves first And then we promised guava fruit action And that's coming Amagro moves first He sends this messenger called Rui Diaz You'll realize in the second while I've gone to the bother of naming the messenger To Manco's huge fortress at Alonte Tambo
但实际上阿尔马格罗先行动了。然后我们承诺了番石榴果的行动。那就要来了。阿尔马格罗先行动了。他派了这个叫鲁伊·迪亚斯的信使。你会在第二秒意识到我为什么要费心给这个信使命名。去曼科在奥扬泰坦博的巨大堡垒
And he says You know Manco You're my great friend If you stand down your forces I'll make sure the king gives you a royal pardon It'll all be forgiven And I'll make sure the pizarroes are punished And Manco is really tempted by this
他说，你知道吗，曼科，你是我的好朋友。如果你撤下你的军队，我会确保国王给你皇家赦免。一切都会被原谅，我也会确保皮萨罗家族受到惩罚。曼科对此确实很心动。
But then another messenger arise from Anando Pizarro who Manco has been fighting all this time and Anando says to Manco you're mad if you trust Al-Magro he's an absolute snake and a liar and anyway he's basically my brother's Francisco subordinate
但随后，一直与曼科交战的埃尔南多·皮萨罗派来了另一名信使。埃尔南多对曼科说，如果你相信阿尔马格罗，那你就是疯了，他绝对是个阴险的骗子，而且无论如何，他基本上是我哥哥弗朗西斯科的下属。
he can't deliver on any of his promises don't listen to him he's a liar all of this so Manco now he's got these two messages and he can't decide which one to go for and he decides he will test Diego Del Margo he's captured four of Hernandez scouts and Manco says well if you are really on my side prove your good faith by executing these four Spanish scouts.
他无法兑现任何承诺，别听他的，他是个骗子。所以曼科现在收到了这两条消息，他无法决定该选哪一个。他决定测试迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗。他俘虏了埃尔南多的四名侦察兵，曼科说，好吧，如果你真的站在我这边，就通过处决这四名西班牙侦察兵来证明你的诚意。
And this is a real dilemma for Al-Magro. If Al-Magro executed these four Spanish scouts, his own countrymen, I mean, the king of Spain would be furious. You see, I think in that situation, Pizarro would execute them. And make an excuse, but Almagro is a bit naive, isn't he? These people have been defending Cusco, can he do it, he can't do it, he doesn't do it. And when Manco hears that he hasn't done it, he says, Gosh, Enando Pizarro is right.
这对阿尔马格罗来说是一个真正的两难境地。如果阿尔马格罗处决了这四名西班牙侦察兵，也就是他自己的同胞，西班牙国王会大发雷霆。你看，我认为在这种情况下，皮萨罗会处决他们，并找个借口，但阿尔马格罗有点天真，不是吗？这些人一直在保卫库斯科，他能这样做吗？他做不到，他没有这样做。当曼科听说他没有这样做时，他说，天哪，埃尔南多·皮萨罗是对的。
Almagro will never deliver. He is a snake. These Spaniards and the final analysis will always stick together. So Manco turns on Almagro. He orders an attack on his army, which is fought off. But then this is the exciting fruit action. Yeah, because what happens to Rui Dias? So Rui Dias is stripped naked.
阿尔马格罗永远不会兑现承诺。他是个阴险小人。这些西班牙人在最终分析中总是会团结在一起。所以曼科转而对付阿尔马格罗。他下令攻击他的军队，但被击退了。但这才是令人兴奋的动作戏。是的，因为鲁伊·迪亚斯发生了什么？所以鲁伊·迪亚斯被剥光了衣服。
He's the messenger who brought a message saying, I'd like to be your friend. And this is his reward. A mad passage, actually. So Rui Dias is stripped naked. And then, and I quote, they anointed him with their mixtures. I mean, who knows what those mixtures are, and were amused to see his contorted features.
他就是那个带来消息说“我想成为你的朋友”的信使。这就是他的回报。实际上是一个疯狂的片段。所以鲁伊·迪亚斯被剥光了衣服。然后，我引用一下，“他们用他们的混合物涂抹他”。我的意思是，谁知道那些混合物是什么，他们看到他扭曲的面部表情感到很有趣。
I mean, nothing good in those mixtures, evidently. Tobasco. They made him drink a great quantity of chicha, that's their kind of beer, and tying him to a post, they used their slings to fire guava fr... I mean, it's the darkest moment in the entire history of the Spanish conquest. Well, I'm about to say, by the standards of the tortures in this series, this is quite...
我的意思是，显然那些混合物里没什么好东西。烟草。他们让他喝了大量的奇恰酒，那是他们的一种啤酒，并把他绑在柱子上，他们用投石索向他发射番石榴……我的意思是，这是西班牙征服史上最黑暗的时刻。好吧，我正要说，按照这个系列中酷刑的标准，这相当……
You've got up really lightly. You'd opt for that, given a choice, wouldn't you? Given all the options, I'd go for the guava fruit every time. But this is weird, isn't it? Because also, they make him shave his beard and cut his hair. Also, again, I would... I wouldn't object too strongly, I think. No, no, no.
你已经很轻松了。如果让你选，你会选这个，对吧？考虑到所有的选择，我每次都会选番石榴。但这很奇怪，不是吗？因为他们还让他刮掉胡子，剪掉头发。同样，我……我想我不会太强烈反对。不，不，不。
What makes me laugh most is the line? They use their slings to fire guava fruit at him, distressing him greatly. And then, yeah, they made him shave his beard and his hair. They wished to change him into an Indian with bare limbs. I mean, yeah, mad torture. So what's going on there? I don't know I'm not an Inca. I can't.
最让我发笑的是那句台词？他们用投石索向他发射番石榴，让他非常痛苦。然后，是的，他们让他刮掉胡子和头发。他们希望把他变成一个四肢裸露的印第安人。我的意思是，是的，疯狂的折磨。那到底是怎么回事？我不知道，我不是印加人。我不能。
There are some points where you just have to throw up your hands and admit that it's an imponderable nature of history. Your powers of imagination let you down. I think Rudy has, I totally agree with you. I think he's got off unbelievably likely. He's had a shave. I mean, people pay for that. He'd pay to go into a sort of posh barber and him to give you a shave. Not to fire a fruit, at you.
有些时候你只能举手投降，承认这是历史不可思议的本质。你的想象力让你失望了。我想鲁伊·迪亚斯，我完全同意你的看法。我觉得他逃过一劫，简直太幸运了。他刮了个胡子。我的意思是，人们为此付钱。他会付钱去那种高档理发店让人给他刮胡子。而不是向你发射水果。
And I guess the guava fruit perhaps has moistened his skin, ready for the shave. You could imagine that being quite fashionable. Hipsters might enjoy it. Pelt a hipster with guava fruit. Then give him a shave. People would pay very good money for this kind of, this sort of treatment. Anyway. where were we with Manco?
我想番石榴可能湿润了他的皮肤，为刮胡子做好了准备。你可以想象这会很时髦。嬉皮士可能会喜欢它。用番石榴投掷嬉皮士。然后给他刮胡子。人们会花很多钱来享受这种待遇。总之，我们说到曼科哪里了？
I feel like Manco's options now very narrow. He can't capture Cusco. I mean, he couldn't capture it before. He can't capture it now. And I think the guava fruit debark has torpedoed any possibility. That's a deal breaker.
我觉得曼科现在的选择非常狭窄。他无法占领库斯科。我的意思是，他之前无法占领它。他现在也无法占领它。而且我认为番石榴的折磨已经摧毁了任何可能性。那是交易的破坏者。
With Elmagro. So he decides his only option is to withdraw to safety and to bide his time and to hope that maybe the Spaniards turn on each other, which of course, you know, he knows them by now. He gets every chance of that happening. So basically he's going to go back to his old life as an outlaw. And so a few days later, he withdraws from his great fortress of Alante Tambo.
与阿尔马格罗的交易。所以他决定他唯一的选择是撤退到安全地带，等待时机，希望西班牙人能自相残杀，当然，你知道，他现在很了解他们。他有很大的机会发生这种情况。所以基本上他要回到他以前的亡命之徒生活。于是几天后，他从他的大堡垒奥扬泰坦博撤退了。
He's going to abandon the Andean highlands of Spanish. He's going to head deeper into the sacred valley. So that's basically in the shadow of Machu Picchu. He's going to go across the mountains and deep into the jungle. And he addresses his supporters. He said, well, people from the jungle have been asking me to visit them for years anyway. So this is the perfect opportunity. I should give them this satisfaction for a few days, he says.
他要放弃西班牙人的安第斯高地。他要深入圣谷。所以这基本上是在马丘比丘的阴影下。他要穿过山脉，深入丛林。他向他的支持者发表讲话。他说，反正丛林里的人多年来一直要求我去看望他们。所以这是一个绝佳的机会。他说，我应该给他们几天的满足感。
And then there are a whole load of prayers led by the high priest. They pack up all their idols and their kind of relics. And they know, you know, realistically, they're probably never coming back. So Manco vanishes and we'll come back to him. And on the 18th of April, Al-Magro rides into Kusko with drums and pipes. Not as a liberator, though. He rides in as a conqueror. He burns the houses of the Pizarro brothers.
然后大祭司带领大家进行了大量的祈祷。他们收拾好所有的偶像和遗物。他们知道，现实地说，他们可能永远不会回来了。所以曼科消失了，我们会再回到他身边。4月18日，阿尔马格罗带着鼓和笛子骑马进入库斯科。但他不是作为解放者。他作为征服者骑马进入。他烧毁了皮萨罗兄弟的房子。
He takes Enando and Gonzalo Pizarro prisoner. He locks them up in the city towers. And then when Francisco Pizarro finally does send a relief column, Almagro rides out to confront them and he persuades them to change sides. So now the balance of power really has shifted. Francisco Pizarro is still on the coast at Lima, but Almagro is ruling unchallenged in Cusco. And he now promotes his own Inca puppet.
他俘虏了埃尔南多和贡萨洛·皮萨罗。他把他们锁在城市塔楼里。然后当弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗最终派出一支救援纵队时，阿尔马格罗骑马出去与他们对峙，并说服他们倒戈。所以现在权力平衡确实发生了转移。弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗仍然在海岸的利马，但阿尔马格罗在库斯科统治着，无人挑战。他现在提拔了自己的印加傀儡。
So this is a guy who's been with him on the expedition to Chile, who is Manco's slightly younger half-brother who's called Paolu. We don't know much about Paolu, although he'll be coming back in the next episode. Paolo is clearly an opportunist. He's much more drawn to collaboration than Manco. He'd much rather collaborate with the Spanish than basically join his half-brother as an outlaw. Paolo gets his supporters to help Al-Magro. And so in July 1537, a few months later,
所以这是一个和他一起去智利探险的人，他是曼科稍微年轻一点的同父异母兄弟，名叫保卢。我们对保卢了解不多，尽管他会在下一集中回来。保卢显然是一个机会主义者。他比曼科更倾向于合作。他宁愿与西班牙人合作，也不愿基本上加入他同父异母的兄弟成为亡命之徒。保卢让他的支持者帮助阿尔马格罗。所以1537年7月，几个月后，
Almagro organizes another grand coronation ceremony in the square in Cusco. He strips Manco of his title as Sapa Inca. I mean, Almagra has no authority to do that. And there's no precedent for it, really, in Inca history. But he basically says, Manco has run away. He's forfeited his title. It's like James II in 1688. and the red ceremonial kind of string fringe with its tassel is given to Paolu,
阿尔马格罗在库斯科广场组织了另一场盛大的加冕仪式。他剥夺了曼科作为萨帕·印加的头衔。我的意思是，阿尔马格罗没有权力这样做。而且在印加历史上也没有先例。但他基本上说，曼科已经逃跑了。他失去了他的头衔。这就像1688年的詹姆斯二世。带有流苏的红色仪式绳带被交给了保卢，
who is now supposedly the emperor. But Manco, of course, has not vanished. Manco has crossed the mountains. He's come down into the jungle into a place called Vilcabamba. And here at a town called Vitkos, he has established his new headquarters, just out of reach of the Spanish. So this is rainforest territory, very much. very wet, wreathed in mist and kind of mystery.
他现在被认为是皇帝。但曼科当然没有消失。曼科已经穿过了山脉。他来到了丛林里一个叫比尔卡班巴的地方。在这里，在一个叫维特科斯的城镇，他建立了他的新总部，刚好在西班牙人的触及范围之外。所以这确实是雨林地带。非常潮湿，笼罩在雾气和神秘之中。
And here, Manco is going to establish an Inca state in exile. And so all is set now for the end game. You have Francisco Pizarro in Lima on the coast. You have Al Magro, his old business partner turned hated rival in the Highlands in Kusco. And you have Manco in his jungle there at Phil Cabamba. There's only going to be one winner. and for at least two of these men, this story will end in unspeakable bloodshed. So one of them will be the last man standing, or will they, and we'll find out which one in the final spine-tealing episode, Tom, of the fall of the Inkers.
在这里，曼科将建立一个流亡的印加国。所以现在一切都为终局做好了准备。你在海岸的利马有弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。你在高地的库斯科有阿尔马格罗，他曾经的商业伙伴变成了仇敌。而你在比尔卡班巴的丛林里有曼科。只会有一个赢家。对于其中至少两个人来说，这个故事将以无法形容的流血结束。所以其中一个人将是最后一个站着的人，或者他们会吗？我们将在最后一集令人毛骨悚然的《印加帝国的陨落》中找出答案，汤姆。
And so the end approaches. And members of the Restless History Club can, of course, hear that episode right away. If you're not a member of the Restive History Club and you want to join them, you know what you've got to do. you've got to head to the rest is history.com and sign up. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以结局临近了。当然，不安分历史俱乐部的成员可以立即听到那一集。如果你不是不安分历史俱乐部的成员，并且你想加入他们，你知道你该怎么做。你必须前往therestisistory.com并注册。再见。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。